So, mal gucken, ob wir jetzt Quality-Settings haben.
Yep, nice.
Können auch die ganzen Low-Internet-Bobs gucken.
Also quasi so gefühlt 50% von Deutschland.
Moin, der Dead Level ist auch wieder am Start.
Leute, ich sag's euch gleich, ich bin auch nicht so gut drauf, ne?
Das liegt daran, ich hatte jetzt einen Monat Urlaub im Dezember.
Ich hatte jetzt einen Monat Urlaub im Dezember, ne, kompletten Monat, und morgen muss ich
wieder arbeiten gehen.
Ich meine, ich hätte ja eigentlich auch nochmal drei Tage Urlaub hinten dran hängen können,
dass ich die Woche jetzt auch noch hätte, oder?
Ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock.
Aber ich weiß, dass sobald ich da bin, ist das mit einer Inordnung, ja?
Das ist bloß immer davor, wo ich keinen Bock hab.
Da denk ich mir immer, ey, ich muss Vollzeit, YouTube, Twitch, sonst was, stellzer werden.
Ich hab irgendwie so heute versucht, Twitch-Partner-Antrag zu machen, und die Twitch-Seite war verbackt.
Ich konnte meine Twitter, Facebook, YouTube und so Accounts nicht verknüpfen, weil man
kann im Partner-Apply-Prozess, kann man ankreuzen, so nach dem Motto, irgendwie already have
audience, andere Plattformen, und wenn man das ankreuzt, soll man dann die verknüpfen,
dass sie gucken können, das verstehe ich ja auch, und das ist verbackt gewesen, das ging
nicht.
Hab mich debatet heute Morgen bei Twitter, weißt du, wenn ich das schon mal mache, ne,
und ich brauch immer noch jemand, der Emotes designen kann, wie gesagt, ich hab mich auch
noch null drum gekümmert, vor allem ich bezahle ja da auch für Kohle, ne, da überlegen wir
uns was schönes, und will, dass keiner für mich irgendwie Emotes umsonst machen muss.
Ich find das immer ein bisschen bescheuert, ja, gerade die Großen, die sich's eigentlich
leisten können, wollen immer noch kostenlos, kostenlose Artworks, äh, Dings kostenlose
Artzeugs haben, ja, von Emotes zu irgendwelchen Channel Designs und so, was eigentlich vollkommen
bescheuert ist, weil, ganz ehrlich, ich glaub, noch kein Künstler konnte von Exposure quasi
überleben, ja, ich glaube, das machen auch nur die Leute, die nicht allzu gut sind, beziehungsweise
nicht allzu lange im Geschäft, weil, ähm, die, die schon ein bisschen länger dabei
sind, äh, die wissen, dass man halt von, äh, man wird verlinkt auf dem Channel nicht leben
kann, und ich find's auch okay, weil einer ordentliche Zeug macht, kann man auch was
bezahlen, das kostet ja keine Millionen, ja, also Leute, ich bin ein bisschen, ich hab
mir heute, äh, vielen Gedanken gemacht um mein Nassbild, und ich hab ein übelst abgedrehtes
Gehäuse gefunden, die Leute, die mir auf Twitter folgen, den hab ich's ja schon gezeigt,
ähm, und zwar, ich hab ein Gehäuse gefunden, hab ein Gehäuse gefunden, das, pass mal auf,
vollkommen abgedrehtes Ding, ja, sieh baro, das wünscht ihr auch, ähm, ich hab ein Gehäuse
gefunden, das, ja, wo zwei Mainboards in ein Gehäuse passen, das ist abgedreht, dass
es sowas überhaupt gibt, aber das ist für meinen Zweck echt cool, ich, ich würde auch
sofort das Gehäuse nehmen, also ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's bestellt, äh, und ich
hab mir mal ein Sample von dem, äh, anderen bestellt, also das, was ich im letzten Stream
ausgesucht hab, äh, hallo, Okram, mit Montes Oma am Start, ähm, und das einzige, was ich
an dem Gehäuse ein bisschen blöd finde, ist, dass die vorne, irgendwie sind die Bilder
übelst rollig, ne, dass die vorne, haben die Staubfilter, das ist cool, die Sache ist
plus die, ähm, hier vorne, das ist nicht gedacht, dass man das aufmachen kann und einen
Wechselrahmen reinstecken, und das hätt ich bei meinem Nass, äh, schon gerne, ja, und
dazu kommt, dass ich, ähm, mir eine Nass-Bild ausdenken möchte, was für jeden funktioniert
und möglichst günstig ist, also ich möchte, quasi so mehr oder weniger, den besten Kompromiss
finden aus, ähm, 10 Gigabit, Zuverlässigkeit und Preis, worum geht es gerade, wir basteln
uns ein 10 Gigabit Nass zusammen, wo ist die Musik aus, weil es vorbei ist, ja, wir brauchen
eine epische Musikuntermalung, das geht heute gar nicht anders, bei, bei, bei dieser Trailer-Musik,
ne, hab ich das Gefühl, das erste, was gemacht werden muss, erstmal Fett-Core und danach
der Rest, kann man auch anmachen, mach doch eins dieser Skyrim-10-Stunden-Videos an, du
meinst, du meinst das Skyrim-Main-Team 10 Stunden lang, oder so, ne, was, was auch übelst
geile, äh, Ambient-Musik ist, für den Hintergrund ist, ähm, die, die alte Dark-Musik, Dark-Ambient,
ähm, die ist auch übelst entspannt, ich mein, ne, die Grafik von dem Game ist halt 2003,
aber die ist auch übelst entspannt, aber die ist schon eher ein bisschen Resident-Sleeper,
da bleiben wir jetzt mal lieber hierbei, ich mach nochmal einen zweiten Browser auf, hier
ist der ganze, der ganze Krempel drin, kann man eigentlich zwischen Chrome und Chromenic,
geht nicht, ne, das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, wenn man da, die, die Tabs verschieben
kann, ja, ich bin so ein bisschen, ich bin so ein bisschen Stuck, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
Wie ich das am besten mache, wie gesagt, es soll ja auch, also, dass ich für mich ein
Gescheites nass rauskriege, ist kein Problem, weil, äh, ich hab noch so viel Zeugs hier
rumfliegen.
Ähm, und im Endeffekt, ich kann auch ein bisschen mehr Kohle ausgeben, wenn's sein
muss.
Du kannst die Tabs verschieben, also ich hab mal eine Zweifel, dass ich zwischen Chromium
und Chrome die Tabs verschieben kann, guck, geht nicht, ich hab mich jetzt auch gewundert.
Delog Adapter, ohne Scheiß, ne, ich mach mich ja da auch immer lustig über das, über
so Adaptergefuddel, aber, die haben coole Sachen, die haben zum Beispiel, pass mal auf,
was es alles gibt, ähm, die haben zum Beispiel einen, übelst abgedreht, die haben nen M2
auf PCI Express, ja ja, ich stimme der Datenschutzerklärung zu, alles gut, alles gut Browser, alles
gut, Moment, äh, hier muss ich noch Uplog installieren, haben wir irgendwie aus Gründen,
die sich mir jetzt nicht erschließen, nicht installiert, und wir haben sie auch noch auf
Deutsch installiert, warum das denn, richtig Woodface, gell, die haben übelst abgedrehte
Dinger, wie zum Beispiel nen M2, äh, M-Key, oder Key M auf PCI Express, vierfach, übelst
gestörtes Zeug, ne, aber, es funktioniert, kann ich euch aus der ersten Hand berichten,
es funktioniert, ähm, brauchst du noch die ganzen Filterliste, ah die Standardfilterliste
ist erstmal ok, was willst du denn für ein OS nutzen, ich benutze nen Ubuntu Server,
ich benutze auf allen meinen Kisten nen Ubuntu Server, ich bin, äh, Ubuntu, Ubuntu Server
Fan, Ubuntu Desktop halte ich nicht aus, Ubuntu Server Beste, ähm, so, ich bin ein
bisschen stuck, und zwar, äh, es gibt jetzt, wie gesagt, ich will ja, dass das ein ordentliches
Build wird, für, im Endeffekt, jeden, und möglichst günstig, und, genau, J-J-Jubuntu,
Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, ähm, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, ja, und, es, es ist ein bisschen, es ist
ein bisschen schwierig, man muss, man muss immer Kompromisse machen, ich mein, die besten
Boards dafür sind wirklich diese kleinen Kackdinger hier, die kosten 70 bis, äh, 85 Euro, je
nachdem was für ne Ausführung man nimmt, ich hab hier schon gezeigt, das, das sind eigentlich
die besten Boards für, weil, die gibt's, ich will jetzt ja nicht zu lange drauf rum
reiten, weil das haben wir uns das letzte Mal gefühlt 3 Stunden oder so im Streben
angeguckt, ähm, weil, die gibt es, ähm, in allen möglichen Ausführungen, also, quasi,
mit, ähm, also, interessant sind eigentlich nur die hier, die gibt's einmal mit 4 SATA-Anschlüssen
und nem, äh, PCI Express 1-fach, oder aber ne 2 SATA-Anschlüssen und nem PCI Express
16-fach, und es gibt noch ne andere Variante, die bringt uns allerdings nix, und die ist
zusätzlich, ähm, sogar nicht mehr ITX, also die passt dann auch schlecht rein, das Gehäuse,
so, und der Witz ist, dass irgendwie alles so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen sackt, ich
mein, für nen, für nen ordentliches Nassbild, also ich hab mir überlegt, was, was brauchen
die Leute so normalerweise, ja, und, ähm, also erstens geh ich davon aus, dass die
Leute in der Regel viel mehr, viel mehr vorschwebt, was sie brauchen, als sie wirklich brauchen,
und das nächste ist, die Leute haben, glaub ich, falsche Vorstellungen davon, ob sie
Raid brauchen oder nicht, weil ich bin immer noch der Ansicht, die meisten Leute brauchen
überhaupt kein Raid, die wollen Netzwerksspeicher haben, die sollen davon gefällig Backups
machen, allerdings sie brauchen kein Raid, weil die meisten Leute da nix drauf haben,
was wirklich live bleiben muss auf ihrem Nass, die meisten, ja, gibt Ausnahmen, bestehen
ihnen die Regel, aber die meisten brauchen eigentlich überhaupt kein Raid, die denken
plus, dass sie Raid brauchen. Ähm, kommt auf das Nass auch Ubuntu drauf, oder eine Nass-OS,
da kommt Ubuntu drauf, ich mein, als Nass-OS, was, du hast ja im Prinzip nur zwei zur Auswahl,
ich weiß, du hast mehr zur Auswahl, aber sag mal drei, sag mal drei, ich mein, das x6-8-Shard
wär, du hast diesen, äh, Cynology-Fork zur Auswahl, ähm, du hast, aber das, weiß nicht,
ich bin auch kein Fan von, von der Cynology-Oberfläche, du hast, ähm, Open, Open Media
Vault zur Auswahl und FreeNAS. So, das sind eigentlich so Dinger, die du zur Auswahl hast.
FreeNAS fällt so ein bisschen für mich raus, erstens, weil es BSD ist, und ich nicht so
den einzig großen Plan von BSD hab, und weil, äh, ZFS nur jetzt nicht ein, äh, für Low-End-Bills
so das Geilste ist, ja, also sprich, das Ding, das kriegt einen 4GB, 4GB RAM-Riegel rein,
da lacht sich ja jedes ZFS schon mal schlapp drüber, und, äh, außerdem stehen die ja
drauf, dass man noch nen ordentlichen HBA drin hat und sowas, das machen wir alles nicht,
wir machen wirklich nen Low-End-NAS-Build, ähm, SSD-Cache, so, so Advanced-Täusch brauchen
wir überhaupt nicht, aber nicht, aber haben wir wahrscheinlich auch gar keinen Platz
für, ähm, weil, wo ich gerade dabei war, das, es ist alles, es ist alles ein bisschen
suckig, ja, also, dieses Board hat 4 SATA-Anschlüsse, was ja prinzipiell schon mal ziemlich gut
für nen NAS-Build wäre, allerdings, wir wollen ja, äh, ermöglicht kein Linux-Tech-Tipps-Bild,
ja, der hat das, ich weiß nicht, ob das das letzte Bild von ihm ist, aber der hat so,
der hat so ein, der hat ein paar 10-Gigabit-Netzwerke, hat er ja ein ganz merkwürdiges Ding gebracht,
ein Video, mit, ähm, 10-G-Karten und dann quasi die Rechner untereinander irgendwie
verkabeln und sowas, wo ich, wo ich mir auch gedacht hab, irgendwie, das ist so, ziemlich
monkey ass, wobei, wer das macht, ist immer so ganz bei der Sache, obwohl ich nicht weiß,
ob das die letzte Geschichte war, auch ja auch nicht jedes Video, so, ähm, was, wie
gesagt, das wär eigentlich von den SATA-Ports das Beste, allerdings, die Sache ist die,
ihr seht's, wir haben nen 1-Gigabit-Netzwerk-Port on Board und wir haben nen PC-Express-Einfach-Slot,
das reicht uns nicht für ne 10-G-Karte, zumal das PC-Express 2 ist, nicht 3, so, ähm,
der hat doch nen 10-G-Gigabit-Switch, AJ45, ähm, der einzige, AJ, halbwegs erschwingliche
Kupfer-10-G, der mir einfällt, ist der von Asus, XX, irgendwas, das könnt sogar der
sein, ne, äh, Asus-10-G-Switch, das ist der einzige, der mir einfällt, der da, der hat
aber auch bloß 10-G, der hat bloß 2 10-G-Ports, Kupfer, aber wie gesagt, Kupfer ist bei 10-G
eh nicht so die beste Variante, erstens brauchst du für jede halbwegs, äh, ja, für jede
halbwegs lange Strecke brauchst du ne ziemlich gute Netzwerk-Kabel und du brauchst relativ
teure Netzwerk-Karten, sag mal so, die günstigste kostet um die 100 Euro neu, ähm, gut, die
mehr Stromkosten, die es theoretisch braucht, äh, das kannst du in der Sache vernachlässigen,
aber bei 10-G ist Glasfaser, beziehungsweise SFP+, die günstigere Technik und ich finde
im Prinzip auch die überlegendere Technik, weil, ähm, wenn du über Kupfer 10-G machen
willst und, und, sag mal hier vom, vom ersten Stock in Keller oder so ein Kabel hast, da
brauchst du ein gutes Kabel, dass das auch ordentlich funktioniert, ja, über, über
2 Meter vom Desktop an, an den Server, der quasi hinter einem steht oder an das Nass,
was hinter einem steht, das ist kein Problem, aber jede halbwegs lange Strecke brauchst
ein richtig gutes Kabel für Kupfer 10-G, ne, der Plan, der Plan ist ungefähr so was
wie, ich, kommt halt aufs Board an und kommt halt drauf an, wie, was, was wir uns da am
Ende ausdenken, also der Plan ist ungefähr folgendes, das günstigste Gehäuse, was 19
Zoll Rack Mounted ist, ähm, mit, nach Möglichkeit, ähm, irgendwie Hotswap-fähiger, ähm, Einbaurahmen
schon dabei, da haben wir schon was gefunden, ähm, das ist natürlich dann nicht die, alles
die krasseste Qualität, aber, ich mein, ich streb ja auch ein Bild an, was, sagen wir
mal, 200, 250 Euro kostet ohne Platten, ja, und das ist schon wirklich ultra lowend für
Kupfer 10-G, nass, ja, also die Platten kommen da auf jeden Fall noch obendrauf, ähm, aber
ich bin der Meinung, das geht, ich bin der Meinung, das geht, das ist ungefähr, ungefähr,
sagen wir mal so, der Ram 25 Euro, das Board 70 Euro, das Gehäuse nochmal 60 Euro, das
Netzteil nochmal 30 Euro, wir nehmen das, wir nehmen so ein kleines, kleines Steckernetzteil
für das Board dann, ähm, da müssen wir, da müssen wir gucken, wie wir das genau machen,
da brauchen wir noch irgendwie 30 Euro für ne, für ne 10-G SFP plus Netzwerkkarte, oder
dem Rest können wir so ein bisschen experimentieren, was, was wir damit machen, so, und wie gesagt,
dass das hier ein gutes Board wegen den SATA Anschluss ein Problem ist, ähm, der PCI Express
einfach Slot, äh, reicht nicht für ne 10-G Karte, ja, wahrscheinlich wird das so ein
Pico Netzteil, also ich geh mal davon aus, ich wird für das Bild, ähm, weil so eins
hab ich hier, äh, noch gehabt am Start und das funktioniert wunderbar, so ein, ähm,
und, äh, also so ein Ding und dann irgendwie so ein 60, was haben wir, gab's so die 60-Watt-Variante,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, genau, nehmen wir irgendwie so ein Netzteil für und dann
nehmen wir irgendwie so ne, gibt die günstigste, die es gibt, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, das
da, was gerade da in der Stadt liegt, oh mein Gott, ich glaube, in ziemlich jedem, in jedem
Stream steht da ein bisschen eine andere Stadt drin, ähm, so, und, und dann sind wir hier
so irgendwie bei, keine Ahnung, 45, äh, 45 Euro fürs, fürs kleine Netzteil, das ist
random, ja, je nachdem, wo das denkt, dass das dein IP ist, ähm, ja, ich glaube, das
ist die Kombi, die ich grad laufen hab, mit dem einen S-Swap-Board, ich glaub, das ist,
ist auch ne Pico PSU, bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob's, ob ich ne 90er genommen hab, was gibt's
da noch für Varianten, 90, 150, 160, ähm, das sieht aus wie ein China, billig-China-Nachbau,
80, oh, das ist ziemlich günstig, das ist ziemlich günstig, warum ist das so günstig,
ist das fake, ist das fake Nachbau, ja, der ATX-Stecker ist 20-polig, aber bei meiner Variante
ist, ah, das ist ne alte Variante, das ist ne alte Variante, ah, okay, ne, die würd ich
nicht mal kaufen, weil die neuen haben schon nen, haben schon den, den 4-Pin-Stecker noch
dabei, ja, genau, sowas hier, sowas hier, und dann ist, ist schon nen 4-Pin-12-Volt-ATX-Stecker
mit dabei, äh, ja, was heißt, der hat nur einen SATA, der hat, der hat einen SATA und
einen normalen Mulex, also den kannst du ohne Probleme mit dem Adapter zu SATA machen, äh,
im Prinzip kannst du aus diesem Anschluss alles machen, den kannst du auch nochmal splitten
in zwei mit nem Adapter, dann hast du, dann hast du zwei Stromanschlüsse für, was du
brauchst, zwei, zwei 3,5 Zoll Platten, die irgendwie aus diesen Gründen noch den Anschluss
haben oder, oder, äh, für, für die, ähm, für den Wechselrahmen, der vielleicht diesen
Anschluss hat, ja, kannst du alles draus machen.
Das hat keinen 4-Pin-Stecker, aber das kann, was, gibt's, ich muss mal gucken, es gibt
bestimmt sogar, es gibt bestimmt nen, nen Adapter von SATA-Stecker auf Ding, auf, im Prinzip
ist das ja, wenn man ja weniger das Gleiche, bloß andere Bauformen.
So, ähm, also das, das ist so ungefähr der Plan, und, ähm, wie ich gesagt hab, das Board
wär gut, aber nicht 10G geeignet.
Die nächste Idee, die ich hatte, so, so, so, die mir dann so, ist mir vorhin beim Duschen
eingefallen, hab ich mir gedacht, brauchen wir 10G oder machen wir, ähm, irgendwie keine
Ahnung, drei, dreimal Gigabit Portchannel, dann hab ich mir angeschaut, was der Scheiß
kostet und was das für ne Formulei ist, und wie für ein Arsch das wahrscheinlich ist
und hab gesagt, nee, machen wir nicht, machen wir nicht, da muss auf jeden Fall ein ordentlicher
10Gigabit Adapter rein, fertig, das heißt, wir brauchen, im Endeffekt, ähm, wir brauchen
mit Gamer duschen, äh, das, ich bin kein Gamer mehr, ich darf das jetzt, ich spiele
zu wenig, um mich als Gamer zu qualifizieren, ähm, ansonsten, wir haben ja gelernt, das
ist alles egal, um Grills zu kriegen, man braucht, ups, man braucht, äh, nur viele
Raspberry Pies, das ist der eigentliche ausschlaggebende Grund, das, äh, verraten einem aber auch
beispielsweise die ganzen Lifestyle-Channels nicht, und am besten ist mal ein Raspberry
Pie Cluster am Start, dann ist das, dann ist das überhaupt kein Problem, dann kommen die
Grills von allein zu einem Raspberry Pie Cluster, gutes, ähm, so, also im Prinzip fällt dann
die Wahl am ehesten noch auf dieses Board hier, weil, das ist das einzige, das einzige
Board, was es gibt, in, in dieser Preiskategorie mit, äh, mit CPU drauf und allem und passiv,
ähm, mit einem 16-fach PC-Express 2, was mich bei den Dingen immer noch übelst fertig
macht, ist der Parallel-Port in 2K19, wünscht ihr auch Informatica Underscore, das ist halt,
das ist halt Hyper, Hyper-Omega-Lull, das Parallel-Port dran ist, aber ich mein, warum
nicht, äh, passt schon, was ich halt, was ich halt geil finde, das, wenn man sich das
hier anguckt, ne, der, der HDMI-Port sieht so voll, so voll aus, ausgegrenzt aus, so
nach dem Motto, Alter, wir sind die Jungs aus 1995 und wer bist du, ich bin der HDMI-Port,
du gehörst nicht dazu, ah, die Jungs von 1990 wollen den HDMI-Port nicht, so sieht
das aus hier, der hat sich, guck, der hat sich quasi, und rechts, rechts, rechts sind
so die Hipster-Audio-Typen, die haben mit den ganzen Sachen eh nix zu tun, ne, Klinke,
Klinke-Audio-Stecker, Klinke-Mikrofon-Stecker, Klinke-Audio-Ausgangs-Stecker, ähm, die,
die chillen so an am Rande rum und denken sich so, äh, äh, weil ich Kacknubs, wenn
die gar nix zu tun haben, ja, und, und wer auch so n bisschen ausgegrenzt ist, der wurde
aber glaub ich entführt von den USB-Anschlüssen, äh, oder zumindest, zumindest, ähm, denkt
er wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch, weil er so outdated ist, dass er ein USB-Anschluss
ist, mein, wer weiß, vielleicht gibt's irgendwann mal Runde-Anschlüsse und das da PS2-Port,
stimmt, ne Joystick-Port fehlt noch, das hätte jetzt noch gefehlt, ja, so, das heißt im Prinzip
läuft's wahrscheinlich auf so n, so n Board raus, wir müssen gleich mal gucken, was es
noch für andere Boards gibt, weil ich bin mir sicher, ähm, wir haben ja letzten schon
geguckt, aber wir müssen mal gucken, was es noch für andere Boards in der Richtung gibt,
dieser Board-Typ soll, soll es halt sein, erstens ist er passiv gekühlt, das ist jetzt
nicht für mich so der große, ähm, das ist jetzt für mich nicht so der große Kriterium
und kleiner dürfte aber auch okay, aber ich mein, so braucht man nix zusätzlich mehr,
hast du eine Anime-Liste?
Nein, hab ich nicht, da musst du den Sebaro fragen, ist das hier der, der Anime-Kennner,
ne oder was?
Sebaro, ich weiß gar nicht, ob du das warst, wir haben hier ein paar, das können auch,
das können auch das Evoli gewesen sein, ich bin mir da grad nicht sicher, genau, ähm,
im Prinzip ist hier halt alles drauf, was man braucht, ähm, du brauchst ein bisschen
kleinere RAM-Variante, aber das ist kein Ding, das kriegt man und hier machst du halt ne
10G-Adapter rein, da hast du, da hast du dann am Ende, hast du dann halt hier für 30 Euro,
es kosten immer viel das Zeug, warum will ich das eigentlich immer auf eine komische Wunschliste
führen, ja?
Du kannst dir den so diesen, irgendwie so einen davon holen, 29,90, die gibt's immer
mal wieder oder, oder man holt sich hier so nen, ah das sind zwei, oder man holt sich
hier so nen Kit, das ist eigentlich auch ganz okay, man holt sich nen Kit, das sind zwei
plus ein Direct-Attached-Kabel dabei, das ist preislich auch okay, man muss sich überlegen,
wo wir auch wieder bei dem sind, Kupfer, Kupfer oder Glasfaser, in dem Fall sieht man halt
hier an der Stelle, man fährt sogar mit Kupfer, ähm, man fährt sogar mit Glasfaser im Endeffekt
besser, also unabhängig von der Technik, mit der man eh besser fährt, man fährt sogar
preislich besser, weil hier kriegste quasi für 30 Euro unter dem Preis, was die einzelne
Kupfernetzwerkarte kostet, kriegste zwei Stück plus nen Direct-Attached-Kabel, also kann
man nicht sagen, das ist für unser Bild die bessere Variante, und die gibt's immer mal
wieder hier auf Amazon, die Dinger, na guck dir, das ist, also die kriegt man ziemlich
zuverlässig, Cisco Mokashake, es ist, es ist nur das Cisco, es ist nur das Cisco Direct-Attached-Kabel,
da musst du dir keine Gedanken machen, Sepharo, ja, ähm, so ungefähr, ungefähr auf dieses,
also wir können ja schon mal einfüllen, was wir auf jeden Fall machen, wir machen hier
die, ähm, als, als Netzteil gibt es auf jeden Fall, als Netzteil gibt's auf jeden Fall
das hier, und irgendwie so nen, so nen 60, 60 Watt, äh, Netzteil, das heißt, da sind
wir zusammen irgendwie bei, ähm, so ungefähr 45 Euro, so in dem Dreh.
Direct-Attached ist Kupfer, ja, ja, wenn ich, wenn ich bei 10 Gigabit von Kupfer rede,
dann meine ich halt, äh, die, äh, AJ45-Variante, also eigentlich müsste ich sagen, SFP plus
und, und AJ45, aber ich sag eigentlich über Glasfaser und Kupfer, was, was eigentlich
nicht stimmt, ne, ne Sepharo, das ist kein Glasfaser, das ist Kupfer, so, und als, äh,
als Gehäuse, das können wir ja auch schon mal eintragen, haben wir das hier, hab ich
mir das hier ausgesucht, also ich, wie gesagt, ich hab mir zwar das hier mal bestellt, einfach
weil ich ein cooles Gehäuse find und mal ausprobieren wollte, und es relativ günstig
ist, ja, ähm, einfach weil ich das mal ausprobieren wollte mit zwei, mit zwei mini, äh, mit zwei
ETX Boards in einem Gehäuse, das wollte ich, das wollte ich mir einfach mal angucken, ja,
ähm, so, und als, als Case bestellen wir das hier, als Case bestellen wir das hier, für
60 Euro, ja, das bestellen wir dann irgendwo da so, hier wo es keine Versandkosten kostet,
65 Euro das Case, und das Schöne an dem Case ist, ähm, da ist wahrscheinlich nicht die
allerqualitativ hochwertigste Backplane dabei, aber es ist ein Wechselrahmen dabei, der Hotspot
fähig ist, das ist schon mal sehr nice, um nicht zu sagen sehr, sehr nice, äh, Case,
nennen wir das hier, das kostet irgendwie 65 Euro, ähm, inklusive 2 Bay 3,5 Hotswap,
das ist dabei, das ist das, was das Gehäuse im Endeffekt auch preislich sehr attraktiv
macht, also erstens ist es, ist es, äh, eine coole Bauweise mit 1,5 Höhenanhalten, das
heißt, du kannst, in 3 HE kannst du zwei Gehäuse stecken, was, was eigentlich ziemlich
blattsparend ist letztendlich für, für 2 Rechner plus, äh, insgesamt dann 4 Einschübe,
ähm, von der Höhe her, es kommt ohne Netzteil, aber brauchen wir ja nicht, unser Netzteil
können wir im Endeffekt hier reinlegen, ja, unser Netzteil kann man hier, kann man hier
quasi reinlegen und, äh, da geht da ein Kabel hinten dran, das ist auch ok, ähm, ah, die
Backplane ist nicht die geilste, haben uns das ja letztens mal irgendwie angeguckt,
die Backplane ist nicht die geilste, aber für unser, für unser, ähm, Low Budget 10G
Nass wird das schon taugen, ja, ich meine, das ist auch, das ist auch noch eine alte
Disko, eine 6G Backplane, das ist keine, keine, ähm, 12, aber das ist ok, weil im schlimmsten
Fall machen wir da eine SATA SSD dran, äh, ja, und dann holen wir uns halt keine mega
teure, die viel schafft und dann kommen wir 6G auch aus, aber es wird wahrscheinlich eher
auf Magnetplatten rauslaufen, ja, aber wohlgemerkt, hier passen auch wieder nur ITX Boards rein,
so, also, das ist, das ist im Prinzip schon mal eine ganz nice Kombi und jetzt kommt der
Knackpunkt bei der ganzen Geschichte, ähm, das Problem ist so ein bisschen, also man kann
sich jetzt überlegen im Endeffekt, wie man es, wie man es machen will, ich muss gerade
mal was nachgucken, genau, also man kann sich jetzt im Prinzip überlegen, wie man es machen
will, man hat halt in dieser, in dieser Variante, das ist halt die günstigste Variante, mit,
mit diesem Board hätte man bloß, ähm, 2 SATA Anschlüsse, das heißt, äh, Speilhümer
kann da zum Beispiel eine SSD dran machen, also das hab ich geplant, ich hab, ich werd
ne, ich werd ne 4TB SSD rein machen, es hat dann zwar nichts mit nem günstigen Bild zu
tun, aber es ist günstig, aber es ist geil, es ist schnell, die F, es ist günstig, günstig
ist ne 4TB SSD nicht, äh, das hab ich geplant und man muss sagen, wenn man 2 Platten rein
macht, ähm, so lahm ist das auch nicht, also so ne normale 10TB Magnetplatte bringt mittlerweile
auch mehr, als ein Gigabit Anschluss, äh, leistet, ja, da machst du 2, machst du zum
Beispiel 2 10TB Platten rein, machst nen Rate 1 und da hast du schon ziemlich zackig
nen Read Speed, also ich geh mal davon aus, dass damit, sagen wir mal, irgendwie so ne,
so ne, so ne, was weiß ich, ähm, sich Speed, Performance, haben die Dinger so, Performance,
wenn die da irgendwas stehen, müssen wir auch gucken, dass sie nicht die für Videoaufzeichnung
genommen haben, ja, äh, bin ich jetzt blind, wo steht dann so die lineare, lineare Lese,
äh, erkenne ichs nicht, wo steht denn was das Ding so ungefähr liest in der Sekunde,
wo soll der irgendwo stehen, Sequential, also die Seite ist wahrscheinlich übelst nice,
aber irgendwie, irgendwie ist die mit zu hoch, ähm, ja, wir accepten das alles, ja, alter,
gehts nicht, also wie gesagt, ich hab ja 3 Stück davon im Rate 5 und der Read Speed
ist sehr nice über 10G, Performance, guck mal, du hast zum Beispiel, ähm, warte mal,
also du hast allein schon mit der Platte, sagen wir mal, 200 MB lesen und, ähm, wenn
du den Rate 1 hast, kannst du die Read Performance, sagen wir mal, so ungefähr verdoppeln, da
hast du 450 MB, hast du 450 MB lesen, dafür lohnt sich das schonmal, das ist doch nice,
was denn sonst, Moment, ne, ne, ne, nicht 450 MB, das Ding liest, ein Gigabit hat 125
MB die Sekunde und die Platte schafft, hab's jetzt schon wieder zugemacht, die Platte schafft
die Sekunde, stand doch hier irgendwo, ne, gehts, ach nee, hier, hier hörst du, seq,
guck mal, 250, sogar noch mehr, 250 MB Read schafft das Ding, 250 MB, das heißt, mit
einer Platte hast du schonmal ziemlich genau 2 Gigabit links voll, das heißt, hast du
den Rate 1 davon, bräuchtest du quasi einen 4 Gigabit Port-Channel geschwuppelt, irgendwie
dass du deinen Read Speed hinkriegst, da lohnt sich ein 10G schon, ja, und wenn wir weitergehen
und sagen, man hat vielleicht nicht nur, nicht nur 2 Platten, sondern sogar 3 oder eventuell
eine SSD, ne, ne 4 Gigabit Quad-Netzwerkkarte reicht nicht, da muss der, da muss dann, sag
wir mal, der Netzwerknoop irgendwelche Port-Channels-Dinger konfigurieren und es ist auf jeden Fall schöner,
wenn das alles über ein Link geht, anstatt, und mal davon abzunehmen, ne Quad, ne Quad-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte
ist fast teurer als die 10G-Karte, ja, ich weiß, dass man das machen kann, aber ich
finde 10G ist auf jeden Fall der bessere Ansatz in dem Fall, spätestens wenn man eine SSD
dabei steckt, ja, eine 4 Gigabit Fiber-Channel-Karte wird auch ausreichen, das ist richtig, ja,
auf den Endpreis bin ich auch gespannt, wie gesagt, ich hoffe ja, dass wir irgendwie
bis um die 250 Euro kommen, so, genau, und das einzige Problem, was es bei der ganzen
Sache jetzt schon gibt, über was wird gerade geredet, über einen 10 Gigabit NAS-Build,
wie man das möglichst günstig und mit Teilen, die quasi sich jeder ohne Probleme holen
kann, wie man sich einen 10 Gigabit NAS-Build bauen kann, die Festplatten kosten ungefähr,
naja, so das 6-Fache oder so vom Server dann, ja, Flo96, wir wollen jetzt aber nicht pipslicher
sein als der Papst, Gigabit sind ungefähr 125 MB die Sekunde, selbst wenn man die 6%
abzieht, dann würde sich eine 10G-Karte noch mehr lösen, ja, genau, Lion, das werden wir
wahrscheinlich auch machen, also ich habe geplant, dass wir vom Preis her ungefähr
von so einem Bundle ausgehen, also sprich zwei Netzwerkkarten mit einem Kopferkabel
dabei für 70 Euro, aber zu 10 Gigabit Netzwerk mache ich eh noch mal ein eigenes Video,
das wird dann auch so in dem Dreh um die 250 Euro kosten, das heißt, wenn man das Setup
macht aus 10 Gigabit Switch mit den 10 Gigabit SFP-Plus-Karten, plus den Kabel, plus das
NAS, hat man im Endeffekt seinen Desktop-PC und einen 10G-NAS für um die 500 Euro gebaut,
ungefähr, ja, ohne Platten, ohne Platten, das ist doch super, da kann man sich echt
nicht beschweren, ich würde auch jedem, Speidel, ich würde auch jedem empfehlen, wenn er das
macht, und jetzt nicht so der Linux oder BSD-Hexor ist, dass er sich da irgendwie ein Open-Media-Vault
oder irgendwie sowas drauf macht, ich werde es nicht machen, ich mache ein Ubuntu-Server
drauf, wie gesagt, ich bin Ubuntu-Server-Fan, ich mache das, und ich richte den Grams eh
lieber selbst ein, ich brauche keine NAS-Oberfläche, wozu? Ich brauche kein Webinterface, um den
Samba-Gest für alle Scherz zu machen. So, das einzige Problem, was wir jetzt haben
bei der ganzen Sache, wie gesagt, bei der Überlegung bin ich gerade, das einzige Problem,
was wir bei der ganzen Geschichte haben, ich hätte es ja am liebsten, dass wir, nachdem
wir bei der Variante hier nur zwei SATA-Anschlüsse haben, ich hätte ja gerne das System nicht
da drauf, also ich will das System nicht unbedingt, außer es lässt sich gar nicht vermeiden,
das System hätte ich gerne auf einem anderen Datenträger, und bei diesem Setup bleibt
ja eigentlich nur ein USB-Stick übrig, wo wir halt die Ride-Geschichten soweit es geht
ausschalten, wobei ich da auch nicht so richtig glücklich mit bin, microSD-Karten-Rate, genau,
wobei ich da auch nicht so richtig glücklich mit bin, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe mal geguckt,
was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, dass man aus einem PCI-Express 16 quasi sowas wie
einen PCI-Express 2x, was weiß ich, 4 und 8 und was weiß ich, irgendwas macht, das sind
aber übelste China-Bastelösungen, die würde ich da nicht reinmachen. M2, ja M2 war mein
nächster Gedanke, da habe ich mal geguckt, der hat leider nur, guck mal, der hat gar
kein M2, und das andere Board hat nur ein M2-Key-E für Wifi-WiFi-Zeug. Also, es ist
alles nicht so schön. So, und dann habe ich mir gedacht, ok, guckst du mal, was es so für
praktische Adapter gibt, weil das Ding hat, PXE-Boot von einem Raspberry- und Hut-Dateilsystem
via NFS-Bot, ist auch eine Variante, die ist gar nicht schlecht, ist gar nicht schlecht,
wenn man ein paar Kisten hätte, die man betreibt, ich meine, für eine Sache, Leute, da würde
man schon USB-Stick dran machen, aber wenn man ein paar Kisten hätte, die man betreibt,
sei es jetzt nur noch ein paar weitere Raspberries oder noch eine zweite Kiste hier in der Richtung,
da ist PXE-Boot gar nicht so verkehrt, wobei ich das halt nicht empfehlen würde einzurichten
für jemanden, der damit noch keine Erfahrung hat, weil PXE ist Fuddelei. Wenn man es mal
gemacht hat, ist es eigentlich kein Ding, dann kriegt man es eigentlich ganz gut hin,
du brauchst irgendwie eine 5-Zeilen-Config oder so, machst IPXE drauf und startest das
Ding, legst dir noch deine ISOs hin, machst einen Eintrag in deinem DACP, installierst
dir PXE sauber und machst dann einen 5-Zeilen-Config-Boot-Ding, ich weiß nicht, wie das bei K, ne, wie
heißen die Files bei, ich weiß nicht mal, wie die Files bei PXE heißen, aber das ist
simpel, aber es ist echt gefrickelt, wenn man es noch nicht gemacht hat, also schön
ist das nicht. Ja, und das, ich hätte halt das Betriebssystem gerne auf einem externen
Laufwerk drauf. Was brauchst du doch eh mindestens 3-4 SATA, ja die haben wir hier aber nicht,
das D-Log SATA-Flash, was soll denn das sein? Ach so, das ist, ach, so ein Teil, ja, sowas
ist cool, sowas ist nice. Genau, an sowas habe ich übrigens auch gedacht, und ich hab
mal geguckt, ob sowas in USB-Variante gibt, weil das ist mittlerweile recht beliebt, dass
wenn man beispielsweise, wenn man sich zum Beispiel von Dell irgendwie eine größere
Kiste holt, die sind ja alle, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die was haben, was nicht vmware-zertifiziert
ist, zumindest wenn man sich eine vmware-zertifizierte Kiste holt, mittlerweile liefern die die
oftmals sogar schon aus, mit einer ESX-Variante drauf, und die sind oftmals aus so einem kleinen
internen Flash-Speicher. Und an sowas habe ich auch gedacht, ob es nicht vielleicht,
weil so ein USB-Stick da hinten dran ist ziemlich doof, wenn man sich da hinten so ein USB-Stick
rausgucken, das ist, es ist irgendwie blöd, ja, und da habe ich gedacht, mal gucken, was
es für Adapter gibt, vielleicht gibt es ja Adapter, wo man quasi einen USB-Stick direkt
auf den Header stöpseln kann. Ich habe es nicht gefunden. Ich habe es nicht gefunden,
was ich gefunden habe, ist einen internen USB-Header, also da Frank, wenn du einen kennst,
dann sag mal was, ich habe keinen gefunden, Freund. Und was ich gefunden habe, ist sowas
hier, vielleicht soll ich es mal richtig schreiben, dann findet ihr auch was. Was ich gefunden
habe, ist einmal sowas hier, bzw. viel schöner, was ist das denn, Moment. Jetzt geht die Musik
aber ab. Du musst jetzt so laut. Was ich gefunden habe, ist sowas in der Richtung,
das ist nicht genau das, was ich gefunden habe, aber sowas in der Richtung. Und das
wäre eigentlich ganz cool. Da kann man sich nämlich so, das ist halt auch nicht teuer,
die gibt es bestimmt, die gibt es doch in billigeren Varianten. Das wäre so im Geiste
von dem, was größere Server-Anbieter schon lange machen, nämlich mit so einem kleinen
internen Flash-Speicher und ich meine, das ist halt USB 3, aber ich meine, ob das jetzt
direkt ans SATA hängt oder an USB 3, kann man sich jetzt überschreiten, ob das SATA
nicht vielleicht ein bisschen zuverlässig ist, aber ich meine, irgendwie müssen wir
auf die 250 Euro kommen. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, das könnte man, also wie gesagt,
da fragt man, wenn du so einen USB-Stick kennst, schick mal her, wäre echt praktisch. Da habe
ich mir gedacht, man könnte einfach so ein Ding da drauf pappen, intern, und man macht
einen kleinen USB-Stick rein und fertig. Die ganz Hardcore-Leute machen zwei USB-Sticks
rein und Backup-Mir-System oder sowas darauf, keine Ahnung. Aber sowas wäre eigentlich
ganz cool, ja. Und es würde halt kein USB-Stick am Gehäuse rumbammeln. Was das Board kostet?
70 Euro, so in dem Dreh. Nein, nicht inklusive Festplatten. Inklusive Festplatten wäre
hart. Da kann man dann, keine Ahnung, eine 80G-Platte reinschieben am Ende oder so. Sondern
als Board wird es wahrscheinlich, ne, wisst ihr was, wir gucken jetzt nochmal, was es
noch für Boards gibt. Genau, die Dell Delophos, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie die internen
Dell Sachen angeboten sind. Ich weiß nur, dass die mittlerweile, die meisten mit einem
ESX oder sowas mit einem ESXe teilweise schon als internen Speicher mitliefern. Und ja,
das könnte USB sein, das könnte aber auch ein SATA-Dings zum Reinklippen sein. Keine
Ahnung. So genau habe ich es mir nicht angeguckt bisher. Aber nachdem ich ja das Glück habe,
morgen wieder auf die Arbeit gehen zu dürfen, könnte ich einfach mal reingucken. Aber ich
habe keine Ahnung. Nein, ich nehme nicht das Board hier. Moment, ich nehme nicht das Board.
Ich nehme das Board. Ich muss das Board, Moment. Ja, ich muss das Board nehmen. Weil nur das
Board einen 16er PC-Express hat. Also wahrscheinlich das Board. Aber ich wollte jetzt nochmal suchen.
Es kostet irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie, sagen wir mal, um die 75 Euro oder so. Ich
wollte nochmal suchen, was es noch für Boards in dieser Richtung gibt. Vielleicht sind die
für diesen Spezialfall besser geeignet. Du verdienst einfach zu viel. Das sagt gerade
der Richtige. Schweizer verdienen noch viel mehr Kohle. Moment, ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
Madden Gamer habe ich noch nicht, aber ich habe vorher bestellt. Ich habe vorher bestellt,
ich habe dieses Case bestellt, was ich verlinkt habe. Das heißt, ich werde es wissen, der
Versand kostet 15 Euro mit DPD. Aber ich meine, es ist ein Gehäuse. Gehäuse kostet
immer ein bisschen was zum Verschicken. So, und wir gucken jetzt mal, was es noch für
Boards gibt. Ich gucke mal, was der Chat gerade geschickt hat. So was hier. Ne, das hat erstens
keine CPU drauf und das ist kein ITX-Board. Ziemlich sicher, das sieht so fett aus irgendwie.
Was ist das? ATX? Ja, Mikro-ATX. Okay, was gibt es für Boards? Es gab von Gigabyte
gab es noch Boards und Gigabyte gab es noch Boards. Äh, nein. Warte mal, Produkte, Mainboards
und Gigabyte habe ich nämlich gesehen, dass die auch noch so Embedded-Dinger haben. Übrigens
sei es noch so viele Leute, die heute wieder dabei sind. Ich hoffe, euch gefällt es. Ich
kann es ja nur ab und zu mal betonen, ich weiß nicht, warum man mir hier so sinnlosen
Ding anzuguckt, aber ich finde es toll, dass es euch gefällt und es motiviert mich auch
regelmäßiger zu streamen, was ich ja jetzt in der letzten Zeit ganz gut durchgehalten
habe. Ähm, ich will Embedded Intel Sockets haben. Okay, das Board ist Suck. Das Board
ist richtig Suck. Das war gar kein PCI Express. Das ist Suck. Das hier hat PCI Express. Das
sieht mir ziemlich genauso aus wie das andere. Das hat ein PCI Express 16. Es ist aber, Moment,
es ist aber eine CPU, die ist nur mal langsamer. Das ist nur ein Dual-Core, kein Quad-Core,
was im Prinzip für unser NAS eigentlich auch ausreichen sollte, solange der IS in Hardware
hat. Aber gehe ich mal von aus. Wir müssen mal gucken. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der
IS in Hardware hat. Ja, hat er. Weil ohne IS ist für NAS ziemlich scheiße. Äh, Knäherberg,
ich habe es von morgen probiert, die Seite hat gebugged. Ich konnte meine Accounts nicht
verknüpfen. Also das Board ist im Prinzip genauso wie das SROC Board, bloß eine schwächere
CPU. Was? Wie viel bringt er? 75 Euro. Was haben sie da? Ich meine, der Dual-Core, der
Dual-Core würde uns auch reichen, weil, wie gesagt, der hat IS Instructions drauf. Ach,
guck mal da. Das ist cool. Das ist, das ist gut. Das müsste doch genau passen, was wir
machen wollen, ne? Guck mal, der hat, der hat, ähm, der hat zweimal SATA, der hat zweimal
SATA, einen PCE Express, einen PCE Express 16-fach und, und einen M2-Slot. Das ist doch
eigentlich gut. Das ist sehr nice. Das, das könnte man doch genau verwenden dafür. Da
machen wir hier den 10G-Adapter rein. Ähm, und in den M2-Slot machen wir irgendwie eine,
eine billige, eine billige M2. Was, was ist denn die billigste M2-SHD, die es gibt? Was
ist die billigste M2-SHD? Jetzt kommt mal besser bei Geizhals. Ähm, M2, die billigste.
Gift, please. 24 Euro. Ach ne, das ist dieser komische Obtain-Crap-Demo aber nicht. 30 Euro.
30 Euro, 128G. Ist das doch ein Schnitt? Äh. M2 SATA oder NVME, das ist bestimmt SATA,
ne? Ne, das ist NVME. Gut. Kann's aber, kann's aber auch. Das wird, das wäre doch genau
das Board was verbrauchen. Das wäre doch genau das Board was verbrauchen im Endeffekt. Das
einzige was mich ein bisschen ärgert ist, dass das nur ein Dual-Core ist. Und im Prinzip
das Board fast das gleiche kostet wie das andere Board mit dem Quad-Core drauf. Ach so,
äh. Ja, gucken wir mal was günstiger ist. Stimmt. Ähm. Stimmt. Ähm. Ja, ist günstiger.
Ja, 20 Euro. Und nehmen wir mal hier irgendwie sowas da, sowas hier. 23 Euro. Ach so, nimmt
sich jetzt an als so viel wirklich, ne? 6-7 Euro. Also das, das Board hier ist von den
Features her viel praktischer für das Build was wir machen wollen. Aber, es ist nur ein
Dual-Core. Was ich irgendwie blöd finde. Ich mein, du kriegst für fast den gleichen
Preis auch eine Quad-Core. Was meint ihr? Also die Optionen sind jetzt, sollen wir so,
die Optionen sind jetzt, ähm, quasi dieses Board hier, das, das, also quasi das Astro
Board mit Quad-Core. Ähm, dann brauchen wir dafür, brauchen wir plus irgendwie den internen
USB-Stick-Header-Dings für das Betriebssystem. Wobei das nicht so schön ist wie eine M2-SSD.
Oder aber, oder aber das, äh, Gigabyte-Board mit, äh, Dual-Core und M2-SSD. Was meint ihr
schöner? Äh, also ich persönlich tendiere beim Board ganz klar zudem, aber, äh, bei
der Auswahl zwischen so einem internen USB-Crab-Stick und der M2-SSD bin ich eindeutig für eine
M2-SSD. Das heißt, es ist wirklich schwierig. Was würde, was, was wäre, äh, Dual-Core
reicht? Ja, äh, Dual-Core reicht auf jeden Fall, aber, ähm, Quad-Core ist besser als
ein Dual-Core. Zumal der Preis kaum ein Unterschied ist. Schafft ein Dual-Core überhaupt 10G?
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert, aber ich bin mir relativ
sicher. Weil die, also ich mein, ich hab ja extra geguckt, das Ding hat, ähm, das Ding
hat, äh, Hardware-IS-Instructions, also sprich, du kannst das Ding voll verschlüsseln ohne
dass du großartig, also, was heißt großartige? Wir können, glaub ich, nach dem Test gestern
sagen, ohne dass du Performance-Einbußen hast und, ähm, das Einzige, was da im Endeffekt
limitiert ist, ja, wie schnell du von der Platte lesen kannst und irgendwie das dann
in die Netzwerkkarte reinpumpen kannst. Das sollte, das sollte sich sogar in, in, in,
in, in, in, 2,7G Quad-Core, äh, Dual-Core kaputtlachen bei. Warum kann Einfach-PCI 2.0?
Hä? Wie, warum kann Einfach-PCI, was, hä? Weil's keine, weil's keine 10G-Karte gibt
für Einfach und Einfach auch keine 10G, äh, schafft. Ich glaub, die, ich glaub, die kleinste
10G-Karte, die's gibt, hat PC-Express vierfach. Also, wir brauchen eigentlich den huge Slot.
Jaja, genau, wegen der 10G-Karte. Wobei ich das, wobei ich das Board eigentlich, ja, eigentlich
finde ich das hier besser. Weil, was, gibt's, gibt's schon eine vier, ich weiß, ich übertreib's,
gibt's schon eine vier Terabyte NVMe. Oh, gibt's nicht. Warum? Ja, ist klar. Ja, ich
meine einfach, es ist erschwinglich. Ja, dass es die gibt, weiß ich. Ich hab, ich hab
letztens auch mal bei Geilsteils geguckt. Das Problem ist, dass, äh, ab vier Terabyte
und da, weil, da gibt's jetzt halt die ersten erschwinglichen von Samsung, geht's dann
weiter mit 1500 Euro. Ähm, aber das find ich nice. Was ist denn das daneben für ein hässliches
Teil? Was ist denn das? Meine Oma hat jetzt gesagt, es ist der Griff zum Fortschmeißen.
Ach, das ist der RAM-Slot von, das hab ich nicht erkannt. Stimmt, ja, von den Klipsen
her. Lol. Das ist der RAM-Slot. Ist aber ein bisschen unglücklich chronographiert, da
kannst du echt denken, das ist, das gehört da hinten dazu. Aber Twitch Chat hat wieder
a huge brain bewiesen. Massive. Donation? Was, ich hab ne Donation gekriegt? TF. The
Game, der Patrick. 13, 13,37 Euro, Dankeschön. Amazon.de, was? Fürs nächste Weihnachten,
wenn's mit dem Grill läuft. Ok, was ist das? Moment, ich mach's mal auf. Was ist das?
Hier wohnt ein Gamer mit seiner Prinzessin. Das tut ja was schon beim Lesen. Das ist
richtig cringe. Ja, das ist huge cringe. Sogar eine Rezession. Gucken wir mal. Fragwürdiges
Material. Wahrscheinlich so wie das Mousepad, was ich dings hier gekauft hab von Steelseries,
ich sag euch Leute hier, ich hab mir so ein Steelseries XQ, ne ne ne ne, ich exkusee.
XMousepad. Das XXL, genau. QCX hieß es, hab ich mir geholt. Und das ist ja sehr beliebt
bei Amazon. Mal, ob man sich die Kundenrezession anguckt. Also fast Lead-Kundenrezession. Und
ich hab auch die XXL Variante genommen. Ich sag euch Leute, also entweder war das ein
Produktionsfehler, was ich gekriegt hab, oder es sterben Leute bei der Produktion. Weil
das hab ich bekommen, hab die Kiste aufgemacht und das hat gestunken wie quasi aus der Halle,
wie ich mir das vorstelle, wie es bei Foxconn beim Plastikschmelzen riecht. Und dann hab
ich es erstmal rausgehängt auf die Terrasse. Das Teil stinkt aber einfach, ja. Ich hab
es rausgehängt auf die Terrasse und dann hab ich es irgendwie vergessen und nen Monat
später, nen Monat, das hing nen Monat draußen. Das ist schon ein paar Monate her, da war
es noch warm. Ähm, das hing nen Monat draußen und ich hab es reingeholt und es hat immer
noch gestunken wie Sau. Dann hab ich es nochmal ein bisschen raushängen lassen und dann hat
es immer noch gestunken wie Sau und hab es weggeschmissen. Direkt, direkt in Müll. Man
kann das in die Waschmaschine stecken, echt. Nach einem Tag war das weg, das hat so abartig
gestunken, ey, das war eklig. Ich hatte es den ersten Tag, weil ich gedacht hab, das
geht weg, hatte ich das hinten in meinem Abstellraum stehen, also da wo der Kühlschrank ist und
da wo der Kratzbaum da vor der Katze mit der Kamera gestanden hat, hab ich das reingelegt
und ich bin da am anderen Tag reingegangen und der ganze Raum war nach dem Ausblatt gestunken.
Das war echt eklig. Waschmaschine wäre ein Obst, man kann das echt waschen. Also, waschmaschine,
ja das abwaschbar ist, ist klar. Kann man? Doch, warum nicht? Oh, das ist die Variante
dick. Also, um mal wieder zurück zu kommen zum Mainboard, das finde ich ist eine sehr
schöne Variante. Warum haben die denn bitteschön nicht dieses Board in der schnelleren Variante?
Weil das Board was die mit der Quad-Core-CPU haben, ist Müll. Das hat nur zwei, das hat
nur zwei SATA und kein, und ein PC-Express einfach. Okay, es hat einen, aber das ist
Müll. Wär der 16-fach wär gut. Wär der 16-fach wär nice, was ist denn das da oben?
Das? Nee, nee, das ist kein PC-Express. Das ist, was ist denn das?
Ach, das ist WLAN. Das ist, ja doch, das kenne ich, das ist, das ist, die machen es
ja kompliziert. Das ist ein M2-Hochkant. Das ist ein M2-Hochkant für Wi-Fi. Das ist
ein M2-E-Key-Hochkant. Weil sie es können. Einfach weil sie es können. Hoffen der Katz
geht es gut. Nee, die Katze die gibt es nicht mehr. Hast du Musik dazu? Das ist ein M2-Slot
nach oben, ja. Ein Key-E, E-Key, Key-E. Kann man immer nicht merken wie Rums, wie Rums
heißt, aber es ist ein E-Key. Key-E, wie auch immer. So, Specifications, müssen wir mal
gucken. Haben die irgendwie so mal eine Übersicht da drüber? Specifications, da oben. Schauen
wir mal. Wir gucken jetzt das erste Mal was, vielleicht ist auch einfach die Übersichtsseite
bei denen kacke. Gemini-Lake heißt der Kram, ne? Gemini-Lake. Mainboards. S-Rock, Gigabyte,
ok mehr gibt es. Asus? Was hat Asus für einen Board? Pass auf, Asus hat jetzt das Richtige,
Asus hat genau das was wir brauchen jetzt. Asus, wie sie ja richtig heißen. Sagt zumindest
derjenige von Asus. Böh, das hat ja gar kein PCIe Express, oder? Was ist das? Das? Ne,
das sackt. Was haben die denn da für komische Dinge auf dem Board drauf? Moment, das muss
ich mir mal kurz angucken. Also was, was, was haben die da drauf? Ram? M2, die sich
irgendwie gegenseitig in die Quere kommen? Wenn ich das richtig sehe. Das Board sieht
nicht so geil aus. Asus. Guten Abend, spielst du noch Battlefield 5? Nein, das habe ich
nicht mehr gespielt. Battlefield 5 ist irgendwie nichts halbes und nichts ganzes. Ich finde
es einfach, man merkt dem Spiel an, dass es irgendwie entweder noch lange nicht bereit
war oder wenig, so wenig Liebe des Entwicklers drin steckt. Das siehst du zum Beispiel schon
wenn du dir das Hauptmenü anguckst. Ich meine wie kann man ernsthaft ein Hauptmenü
von einem 2. Weltkrieg Spiel absolut nicht nach 2. Weltkrieg aussehen lassen. Also ich
meine das Overlay und das Menü und das sieht aus wie Battlefront, bloß nicht wie 2. Weltkrieg.
Qualität, 5-fach Schutz. Ahja, ist das so. Wenn sie das sagen wird das so sein. M-Key,
ok. Aus dem M-Key kann man theoretisch einen PCIe Express glaube ich 2D4, ach keine Ahnung
machen, aber das ist wieder gefrickelt. Also das Board ist nicht gut. Da fehlt ja so ziemlich
alles was die anderen Boards ausgezeichnet haben. Das ist die langsame CPU und hat weniger
Schnittstellen. Das ist sinnlos. Was hat die nix größere Variante noch? Die hatte aber
glaube ich auch noch ein 1-fach PCIe Express. Ja gut, also im Prinzip bleibt uns nix anderes
da übrig. Es bleibt eigentlich nur noch dieses Board hier. Bleibt dieses Board hier oder
dieses Board mit USB Stick. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt den Dual Core besser finde. Ok dann
nehmen wir mal das hier, kostet 75 Euro das Board. Ok, Netzwerk, ungefähr 30 Euro die
Karte. In das 19, das waren 2 Boards. Ja in dieses Gehäuse, in dieses Gehäuse was
ich vorhin gezeigt habe, das ist für 2 Boards. Aber das hier kommt in ein anderes Gehäuse,
das kommt in ein Gehäuse mit einem eventuell fragwürdiger Backplane, wo man nicht genau
wissen wie gut die ist, aber es hat zumindest einen schon den Preis dabei. So RAM, RAM fehlt
uns jetzt eigentlich nur noch. Also Hardware, Arbeitsspeicher, DDR4 RAM. Ja das kommt in
ein 1,5 Gehäuse, in das da. Das andere habe ich mir nur mal bestellt, weil ich schon immer
mal einen 19 Zoll Rackmount haben wollte, das 2 Boards aufnimmt irgendwie. Wird das
übelst nice. Er kann sich ja ein paar Optionen offen halten. Das kommt in dieses Board rein,
in dieses Gehäuse. Das Gehäuse sieht auch ziemlich leicht aus, wahrscheinlich braucht
man auch nicht mal Schienen, wahrscheinlich hält das auch wenn man es einfach festschraubt.
Aber die haben bestimmt Schienen. Kostet das offizielle Netzteil von denen? Kostet das
offizielle Netzteil von denen? Also nicht dass wir das kaufen werden oder so. Kostet unbekannt.
Netzteil 45 Euro. Siehste das Netzteil ist sogar noch billiger als unser Pico PSU Netzteil.
Kostet das gleiche. Mikro ATX kann man machen, hast aber wieder andere Probleme, Mikro ATX
wird teurer. Mikro ATX wird teurer, das passt zum Beispiel nicht in das Gehäuse rein und
die Boards in dieser Preisklasse, also sprich mit dieser CPU drauf, mit dieser Gemini Lake
Geschichte, die gibt es bloß mit, die gibt es eins von Astro in Mikro ATX und die haben
einen 1-fach, einen 1-fach und einen 16-fach Slot, was uns im Endeffekt nicht viel bringt.
Das einzige was man machen könnte damit ist, wobei es dann halt wieder das Bild auch ein
bisschen durch den anderen wirft. Das einzige was man damit machen könnte zum Beispiel
ist eine 10G Netzwerkarte und irgendwie so eine 1-fach Karte, 1-fach PCI Express Karte
mit noch ein paar SATA Ports drauf. Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit. Aber dann brauchst
du auch wieder ein komplett anderes Gehäuse. Also das wird auf jeden Fall teurer die Variante
dann. Man muss im Endeffekt einfach gucken was passt. So, also Boarddings Speicher wollten
man mal gucken. Ab 8GB, 4G gut ist. Was auch schön ist an dem Gigabyte Board, wenn ich
das richtig gesehen habe, die haben normal große RAM Slots. Die haben normal große RAM
Slots, das heißt man braucht keinen Miniatur RAM oder wie heißen die überhaupt? DIMM 0,
DDS 0, braucht keine kleinen RAMs. SD RAM ist ja im Endeffekt alles. Ne, nicht SD RAM,
die haben normal lange RAM. Danke. Ja das ist nice, das heißt wir können dann den billigsten
RAM drauf pappen den es gerade so gibt. Also sagen wir einfach mal 25 Euro für 4GB. Gibt
es auch welche mit Embedded Ryzen? Da gucken wir doch gerade mal. Embedded Rützen RAM kostet
25 Euro und 4GB, das reicht. Wo gibt es die Boards? Ok, das ist auf jeden Fall kein
RAM. Das sieht aber teuer aus. Geben wir den ab. Wie heißt denn die Plattform für Embedded
Ryzen? V1000? Doch, das ist doch ein Mini-ETX. Das sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie ein Mini-ETX
oder wie ein ETX Board. Die Drehchen sehen übrigens fett aus. Thicc, huge. Wirklich viel
zu sehen gibt es da noch nicht ne? Und das kostet wahrscheinlich viel. Hast du mal einen
Link dazu? Also ich finde es nix gescheites zu Embedded Ryzen Linkern. Gut. Also die können
in den Krams... Was kostet es? Ja, ok. Da kostet im Prinzip das Board schon 100 Euro
mehr als unser komplettes System. Aber das könnte eine Alternative sein für Systeme
die ein bisschen mehr Wumms haben. Was da? Das Firma HDMI? Ich weiß nicht ob das die
richtige NAS-Plattform ist. Die haben ja auch kaum storage slots. Aber ich muss sagen,
ich finde die Sache hier nicht schlecht. Das Gigabyte Board gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich gut. Ja, 4 Gigabyte ist mehr als die meisten Konsumer. Zumindest die low-end
NAS Geschichten. So Leute, habe ich jetzt irgendwas vergessen. Was wir noch brauchen.
Ram, Netzwerk, das Case, das Board, da ist die CPU mit drauf und das Netzteil. RGB-Beleuchtung,
ja. Vielleicht ist ja noch Platz für RGB-Beleuchtung. Quickmaps. 45 plus 57 plus 65 plus 30 plus
25. Das sehen wir doch gut im Preis dabei. Also können wir uns noch 10 Euro RGBs kaufen.
LED. Oh, habe ich mich vertippt? Habe ich mich vertippt? Passt doch. Ach, nur falsch
gesagt. Ja, das kann schon mal passieren. Im Alter kommt das immer häufiger vor. Kann
man nichts gegen machen. Ich würde sagen, die 10 Euro sind mal pro Verwirf Versandkosten
und sowas. Man sollte das zwar alles so bekommen ohne Versandkosten, zumindest wenn man Prime
hat. Oder man den passenden Job bestellt. Aber 10 Euro plus minus ist nicht verkehrt.
Sebaro, ich habe doch heute Quality Options. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt noch. Ach, Moment.
Moment. Wir haben noch was vergessen. Wir haben noch was vergessen. Wir haben die SSD
beziehungsweise den USB-Stick vergessen. Also kommen wir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
drüber. Die SSD hat irgendwie 20 Euro gekostet. Irgendwie um die 20 Euro. Die 128G. Die brauchen
wir noch fürs System. Mikro SD-Card, ja gut. Alternativ USB-Stick. Alternativ USB-Stick,
der halt dann nichts kostet. Keine Samsung-SSD. Nee, was hatten wir? Ich habe vorhin einfach
die billigste SSD-Marke geguckt, die es gibt, die aufs Board passt. Da kann man ja variieren
letztendlich. Die SSD muss ja am Endeffekt auch nichts können. Die muss das Betriebssystem
booten. Und der Vorteil finde ich jetzt auch, dann ordentliche SSD reinzumachen im Vergleich
zu der USB-Stick-Variante ist, man kann damit einfach mehr machen. Also wie gesagt, ich
werde ja eh, da hatten wir hier notiert, ich werde ja eh auf der internen Kiste ein bisschen
mehr laufen lassen. Ich werde noch ein Nextcloud drauf laufen lassen. Das braucht ja am Endeffekt
auch keine Leistung. Kommt ein LXT-Container rein, den Fritzbox-Kontakt, der Anrufmonitor
braucht auch keine Leistung. Da ist vollkommen egal, ob Dual-Core oder Quad-Core. Nächliche
Backup-Geschichten, ist auch egal, ob Dual-Core oder Quad-Core. Mail-Sync ist auch egal,
ob Dual-Core oder Quad-Core und PXE-Boot und ein Git Frontend. Also da macht die CPU jetzt
auch nicht fett, das eilt eh nur rum. Jetzt müsst ihr immer 2K19 schreiben, das ist richtig.
Es ist schwierig, aber es wird schnell vorbei sein. Also sowohl 2K19 geht wahrscheinlich
auch wieder schnell rum, aber auch dass man 18 schreibt, geht schnell. Wollte grad noch
mal gucken, SSDs. Jetzt haben wir es irgendwie falsch gefiltert, oder? Ja, jetzt haben wir
es richtig gefiltert. Ja, sowas hier können wir uns holen für 23€, gut ist, bam. Dann
sind wir bei 263€. Und davon ist kein einziges Teil irgendwie im Angebot, sondern sonst
was, das heißt wir können wahrscheinlich auch noch die ein oder anderen Sachen sparen.
Muss mal gucken, wo es da noch Optimierungspotenzial gibt. 2K18++, aber das ist eine gute Schreibweise,
das ist eine leiste Schreibweise. Hier, warte mal, wir gucken mal, wie viel wir wirklich
jetzt vom Preis her hinbekommen. Also, wie genau macht man sich denn noch mal Geiz-Hals-Wunschlisten?
Ah ja, Lokal-Wunschliste, krass, krass. Ok, ich weiß nicht ob wir die Pico PSU da bekommen.
Oh, das ist mega billig. Nee, die war schon immer so billig, vergesst. So, Wunschliste
hinzufüllen, naas, jop. Dann brauchen wir noch irgendeinen Kanal, so 60 Watt oder sowas.
Was hatten wir da vorhin bei Amazon gesehen? Hier so 60 Watt-Netzteile oder sowas. Wieso
keine GPU, weil das nass wird? Da brauchen wir keine GPU. Und die onboard GPU für HDMI
reicht ja auch. Was davon abgesehen, wahrscheinlich haben die meisten Leute davon sogar ein Netzteil.
Kosten sowas hier. Irgendwas billiges, so. Irgendwie sowas hier, es ist eigentlich vollkommen
egal. Netzteile, Ladegeräte. Ah, das dürfte ein bisschen wenig sein, ne. Oh, was ist das?
Wie sieht denn die andere Seite aus? Das? Keine Ahnung. Ok, unter 60 Watt geben wir mal nicht.
Aber wenn man da noch zwei Platten dran hängt, die müssen beim Anfahren noch anfahren und
die Apple-Universal-Netzteile. Ok, was das alles so gibt. So, machen wir das mal in die
Playlist, in die Wunschliste. Das, so, erfolgreich hinzugefügt. Was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Wo guckt man sich jetzt die Wunschliste an? Wunschlisten, da. Das. Ok, jetzt haben wir
das Board brauchen wir jetzt. Das Board. Oh, das schwankt aber ganz schön, ne. Ne, macht
es nicht. Das sind nur zwei Euro Unterschiede, sieht aber so viel aus. Zur Wunschliste hinzufügen.
Das Case haben wir. Ja, Netzwerk können wir nicht hinzufügen. Das ist ja Amazon Marketplace.
Die finden wir immer über Geiz, als wären wir die nicht finden, denke ich. Ne, guck,
hier geht es ab 79 Euro irgendwie. Ne, die finden wir hier nicht gescheit. Da muss man
auch bei Amazon gucken. Bei Amazon. Amazon. Ne, die finden wir hier nicht. Ram hatten wir
mit dem billigsten DDR4 einfach reingepackt. Alter Leute, ich hab keinen Bock morgen wieder
arbeiten gehen mitzumüssen. Überhaupt gar nicht. Arbeitsspeicher, RAM. Wir können normalen
RAM nehmen. Da ist eigentlich egal, was wir nehmen. Da kann man jetzt so auswählen. 4
GB DDR4. Alles der gleiche Krampel. Dann nehmen wir das billigste einfach. Das sieht hässlich
aus. Aber RAM muss nicht gut aussehen. Dann brauchen wir noch eine SSD. Da machen wir
auch wieder die billige RAM. Ne, Quatsch. Da. Irgendwie das Ding hier. WD Green ist die
energiesparende, energiesparende SSD. Die Dinger brauchen doch alle nix. Nur Wunschliste
hinzufügen. Was? So, Wunschlisten. Also, das dürfte so ungefähr unser Nassbild werden.
Ob es was taugt, seh ich erst, wenn ich es hier am Start habe. Ja, vorhin hatte ich noch
M2 auf PC express. Genau. Aber das ist eigentlich egal. Das ist vollkommen wurscht. So, 10823.
Da kommt noch die Netzwerkkarte drauf. Darf man nicht vergessen. Die kostet auch nochmal
32 Euro. Oder sind wir doch ungefähr bei dem Preis, den wir angepeilt haben? Bloß eventuell
noch ein bisschen versandt, je nachdem, wie man es macht. Aber es sind so ungefähr 250-260
Euro. Also das dürfte somit die günstigste 10G, das günstigste machbare 10G Nassbild
sein, was man sich so vorstellen kann. Vor allem 19 Zoll rack mountable und mit einem
Wechselrahmen dabei. Eigentlich ganz cool. Wie gut das Ding ist, muss ich mal gucken.
LogX HD. Ja, ein nicer Router. Nasszusammenbau im YouTube Unboxing. Könnte man sogar machen.
Ich habe ja eh vor diesem Monat, ähm, äh, nicht diesem Monat, dieses Jahr, da mache
ich dann Max Tech Tips. Ne, diesen Monat, äh, was habe ich mit Monat, Alter? Dieses
Jahr will ich eh so eine Mischung aus Gaming und Technik Videos machen. Halt aber auch
zu Themen, wo ich mich mit auskenne. Also nicht gerade zu Desktop Hardware. Router,
Router, ja. Aber ich finde das Bild ist doch wirklich nicht übel. Ich war wohlgemerkt,
das Ziel ist es, ein, ein, somit das günstigste 10G Nass zu bauen, was man sich so vorstellen
kann. Was allerdings, äh, auch zuverlässig ist, ja. Also ich meine, wir könnten auch
bei AliExpress irgendwelche falsch gelabelten SSDs bestellen oder so und Mainboards. Aber
wir gucken jetzt gerade mal. Haha, wir gucken jetzt mal, wir gucken jetzt mal in China.
Wir gucken jetzt mal in China, was die so haben. Okay, was, was gibt es in China?
Das sind alles Fertig-PCs, das ist langweilig. Das bringt uns nichts. Die B-Link. Hat er
einen PC-Express-Ausgang? Ne, ne? Hat er nicht. Das ist kacke. Das sind alles Fertig-PCs,
das bringt uns nichts. Okay, das ist in China, gibt es auch nichts. Was kann ich mir denn
da empfohlen? Das für ein mega hässliches Board. Ein unbekanntes China, äh, TX-Board.
Man weiß nicht so genau, was drauf ist. Von 2013, Jahrwetterbestellung, Atom, oi, oi,
oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi. Boah, das ist aber ganz was anderes. Support, äh Support-RZ.
Ich guck gerade, was es bei AliExpress gibt, ums billiger, also ob die das billiger könnten,
als das, was wir zusammengebaut haben. Wir sind ja mit dem, das Bild ist ja schon, steht
ja mehr oder weniger. Ich will jetzt mal gucken, ob es bei AliExpress irgendwas gibt, was noch
noch billiger wäre aber das scheint wirklich ganz gut zu sein was wir
zusammengebaut haben weil sogar die chinesen haben nix billigeres
was könnte was könnte man noch was könnte man noch hiervon sparen bei
aliexpress also ich werde das nicht bei aliexpress order ich will einfach
wissen ob die chinesen noch billiger hinkriegen könnten
nvr ssd haben die bestimmt haben die bestimmt billigere auch nicht mal das
netzteil oh ja das genau wir das netzteil oder bei aliexpress
dann ist ripp haben gesagt
ja die haben bestimmt so eine pico psu nachbauer haben die bestimmt was sollen
das sein
ich erkenne auch nicht mal was es ist aber meinung meinung netzteil
guckt mal es ist sogar guckt euch das mal an auf aliexpress ist es teurer passt
ne ne 10 euro billiger ja ok syste bei aliexpress hätten wir
schon mal 10 euro im netzteil gespart gespart heißt einfach auch pico psu
die kennen die kennen da nichts die chinesen auch immer es geht noch
billiger das aliexpress netzteil die sie ja
aber die haben den strom stecker vergessen oder die haben den strom
stecker vergessen wo ist der strom stecker oder soll der strom stecker 6
pinf email sein wo ist der strom stecker
ja ich glaube dass er ist der strom stecker
ne ne ne das hat kein strom stecker ich habe den strom stecker vergessen wir
machen den netzteil ohne strom stecker das kann auch nur auf china kommen so
was oder wo ist der strom stecker das gibt es doch nicht das kann ich nicht
ernst mein irgendwo muss man ja sparen gut package oder ist das wirklich ist
wirklich in 6 pin input strom stecker kann eigentlich nicht sein keine
wo das strom stecker ist guck die haben wenigstens strom stecker dabei input 6
stand das wirklich da ja 6 moment 6 pin in viel um alles in der welt schließt
man das an
6 pin input schließt man das dann an netzteil an das netzteil oder was also
ich schließt dann quasi anstatt genau ich schließt dann anstatt eine grafikkarte
an netzteil ein netzteil an um mit dem netzteil den zweiten rechner zu
betreiben wo ist denn da von die logik jetzt easy china netzteil hat das 80 plus
zertifizierung hat wahrscheinlich 80 minus zertifizierung das ist so wie
manche wie manche china house dann in ihre slas sind auch quasi in down time
statt sind ab time wenn man sich das anguckt gefühlt
ne also netzteil jeden fall kaum war das nicht bei aliexpress also man sieht man
könnte wenn man wenn man sehr mutig ist könnte man noch mal 15 euro sparen am
netzteil bei aliexpress oder sogar mehr oder sogar mehr
oh man konnte viel mehr sparen guck mal für 2 euro 43 krieg ich dann ein
schwarz netzteil das traue ich mich nicht anzuschließen oder sieht auch
schon das sieht auch schon mal super safe aus hier muss dann die stecker
noch selbst dran machen ja so was hier easy ok also ohne scheiß wenn wir bei
aliexpress bestellen würden könnten wir 30 euro oder so sparen 30 euro für beim
netzteil ja nicht offensichtlich weiß es ist mega billig ich habe ich habe mir
eine packung not im not mcs gekauft
kostet nichts
kostet ich kann dir nicht sagen welchen nachbar ich mir geholt habe das weiß ich
nicht mal
der delivery time kommt drauf an das ist das ist bei aliexpress ist das gar
nicht so gar nicht so einfach die haben ja die haben ja die unterschiedlichsten
die unterschiedlichsten lieferdinger das beste lieferding ist niederländische
post
was die jetzt aber anscheinend nicht anliefern weil man muss wissen
aliexpress ist ein bisschen wie ebay insofern dass dort quasi shops anbieten
also die ist nicht wie amazon dass das meiste zeug von aliexpress verkauft wird
aliexpress stellt nur die plattform also die das sind alles hier unterschiedliche
shops das heißt die haben auch alle leicht unterschiedliche delivery und
shipping gedöns amazon können auch shops reiten dass
aliexpress mehr oder weniger nur shops sind also sprich wenn man für einen
eindollar kiste gerne 20 dollar versandkosten bezahlt kann man das tun ich
würde lieber sowas hier nehmen aliexpress standard shipping das
könnte sogar das sein mit post nl das könnte sogar die post nl geschichte
sein
aliexpress standard shipping ist ganz okay ich habe da schon ein paar dinger
bestellt das je nach versandmethode dauerte schon mal drei wochen aber
manchmal geht es auch ganz schnell
und je nachdem welchen shop wir gehen die haben immer ein bisschen in der hand
die haben jetzt mehr oder weniger die gleichen aber die haben immer ein
bisschen andere shipping und solche sachen
und hier haben sie und hier haben sie zum beispiel shipping ich glaube das
letzte mal ich mit aliexpress standard shipping bestellt und die verschippern
das ja irgendwie mit der niederländischen post also wenn man das
richtige hier auswählt ja mir irgendwie so als world wide
dingsbums partner die niederländische post und ich gehe mal davon aus dass das
auch daran liegt dass man so selten post vom zoll bekommt wenn man aliexpress
bestellt also ich gehe mal davon aus da bin ich natürlich strikt dagegen ja
muss ich jetzt hier mit sagt es einfach nicht im stream natürlich strikt
dagegen sowas ist ganz schlimm ich gehe mal davon aus dass die es mit post
nl einfach geschickt machen und auch in den bullshit auf paket schreiben so dass
es der zoll nicht erkennt also mit aliexpress hast du relativ wenig problemen
was zoll anbelangt
die wissen anscheinend wie man das machen muss
so aber ehrlich leute aliexpress
aliexpress netzteile will ich nicht für das bild bezahlen nicht kaufen
ja gartenschlauch auf usb dass auch da ist
wir gucken mal wir gucken mal was da wir gucken mal was da eine netzwerk karte
guck mal hier die chinesen
und acht ane das ist nur sfp ok moment ich habe nein falsch
wie sucht man das sfp plus will ich suchen fp plus darf man nicht
magst hast du eine prille nähe ich habe nur ich habe eine ich habe eine ich habe
eine granner optik granner optik scope habe ich die hier quickscope
aber nicht weil ich eine prille brauche sondern für den für die bessere acht
stunden am pc sitz experience
je nach fs fp plus darf man hier nicht suchen
fp plus 10 g in fiber optics equipment warum kann ich nicht nach 10 g suchen
doch jetzt
ja hier können die chinesen auch nicht so richtig mithalten das ist das lohnt
sich jetzt nicht wirklich ah glasfaser optics 10 g sfp plus eindeutig
das ein hunting scope dass ich bei aliexpress alles holen kann
gut an netzwerke equipment kann man nicht ordentlich suchen naja egal nach sd
kann ja sd karten sind auch übelst billig micro sd 32 g
in memory kratz oder micro sd kratz easy 2 dollar stück überhaupt kein
problem überhaupt kein ding 32 g 3 euro 45 kein ding
ja das ordentliche shipping kostet aber da kann er sich richtig mit sd karten
ein ein decken er kriegste da kriegste
man he moment die versandkosten verwirren mich gerade
aliexpress shipping mit aliexpress shipping also du kriegst 26 26 32 g
micro data micro sd für 100 dollar also kein problem
wollen wir bestellen auf geht's
leute ich glaube nicht dass das gemm ist ich glaube das ist wirklich legit 32 g
ssd ist micro ssd micro sd ich habe es heute mit wörtern nicht so bestimmt
bestimmt was kostet es denn auf amazon zur zeit 32 g micro sd karte 10
ne genau die hier 8 euro 8 euro kostet kleinste kostet 6 euro ok nimm mal die
kratzen 6 euro 6 euro bei aliexpress kostet die hälfte gibt es da auch
reviews ja jede menge aber da hast du halt alle möglichen reviews russische
reviews moment die stehen doch sonst hier immer ja recht reif ist gut wat for my
phone ist noch zutun
wat wei
guckt mal nach usb sich das kostet auch nichts so zeugs kann man immer gut bei
aliexpress bestellen das ist das kostet da echt immer einen appel und ein ei
das kostet nichts im endeffekt und die russin bestellen gerne in aliexpress
du siehst jetzt auch viele russische bewertung immer aber ich glaube die ich
glaube der versand nach russland ist auch schneller von china aus als nach
deutschland das ist ja mehr oder weniger direkt
unten drunter russer ist halt groß all gut workin
ah ist der wonderful stick ja hey amazon bewertung sind auch faked
teilweise geht mit der musik ab ups es geht übrigens bestimmt noch billiger
da was kostet guckt mal was kosten die sandisk die sandisk die kostet schon
die kostet die kostet schon so viel wie bei uns naja nee nee bei uns das stimmt
nicht bei uns kostet noch mal vier euro mehr
äh ach nee guckt also ich ich ich würde mir ja eher die die 256 g was gibt's
auch die sind im angebot gerade leute
aber kann auswählen ob man von russland oder von china aus schippen will
please select country you want to ship from you know cannot deliver to germany
feels bad man stelle mal auf euro um ja mache ich gleich ja was kostet jetzt
genau ich glaube das ist immer noch viel viel billiger als als bei uns
aus die samsung samsung
ja ach nee guck mal das bringt überhaupt nichts in china zu bestellen das ist ja
man muss immer genau gucken aber es immer genau gucken bei uns sogar billiger
hast du erfahrungen mit dem skrl updater in sich habe nur ein bisschen mit
rumgespielt nichts großartig gemacht bisher euro
ja das lohnt sich nicht das lohnt sich nicht so ganz bei uns billiger aber
mikro data mikro data
ich sag mir halt vom hersteller absolut null
aber man bekommt halt einfach mal 30 stück für 100 euro 30 32 g mikro sd
ist schon das eigentlich nicht schlecht braucht zwar kein mensch
ist preislich weiter findet ihr nicht auch dass 30 400 besser klingt als 10
für 33
wir haben noch weitere hochqualitative sd karten von mix mix zwar weltbekannte
marke mix zwar mix 32 g dürfte preislich so ungefähr top top designed aus ist
sogar noch einen ticken günstiger wie mikro data beides marken ja wie gesagt
weltbekannt da kriegste für genau 100 euro inklusive
versand 30 mikro sds
rgb mikro sd rgb
nein so nicht mal die chinesen haben mikro sd karten mit rgb beleuchtung ja
und wenn einer usb sticks braucht usb sticks in selfies das ist auch unglaublich
billig hier das zeug
was machen wir mal 64 g in 60 g wellendorf credit card usb flap das
kreditkarten scam oder was soll das sein
ok nehmen wir mal den sonn trissi 64 g
ach so was color muss noch auswählen black hier macht keinen unterschied das ist
aber relativ teuer oder wie viel kostet das bei uns so 64 g
usb stick ok es ist nicht teuer habe ich gesagt ich habe nichts gesagt also
billigste bei uns kostet zehn euro ja aber so der riesen unterschied ist es
jetzt auch nicht das lohnt sich nicht das lohnt sich erst wenn es nur die
hälfte kostet wie gesagt ich habe mir auch meine ganzen fenster und door
sense seawave fenster und door sensoren bei aliexpress gekauft und die haben
weniger als die hälfte gekostet mal gucken was die aktuell kosten
wieder zu teuer wieder zu teuer ich habe die damals für 10 dollar gekriegt das
stück die hier wieder zu teuer muss man wieder warten bis angebot ist das lohnt
sich bei aliexpress übrigens richtig die angebote anzugucken bei denen sind die
angebote habe ich das gefühl nicht so amazon gbait sondern teilweise wirklich
65 prozent und so was
ja nachher muss die cookies löschen aber so ist ich finde die die amazon
angebote sind nicht gemm in dem sind die amazon angebote sind so wir schreiben
halt nachlass von 60 prozent dran obwohl es vorher halt nie 60 prozent mehr
gekostet hatten bei allen anderen anbietern oftmals auch nicht viel
weniger kostet das ist die amazon angebote zum größten teil gbait wo die
amazon angebote wirklich gut sind ist für amazon eigenes zeug wer hätte das
gedacht ja zum beispiel in feier hat die kaufen für 95 euro anstatt 150 das ist
gut
ok leute wollen wir noch irgendwas suchen jetzt bei aliexpress wo wir gerade
dabei sind habt ihr noch irgendwelche vorschläge wollt ihr etwas gucken
ansonsten bin ich mit meinem nass bild echt zufrieden böller feuerwerk
was kosten feuer gut ist jetzt vorbei aber
was ist das dann ist das ist das hier zum bomben bauen oder was schwarz
polva mit heff was ist mit aliexpress los
was mit aliexpress los tauschen die terroristen ein oder was
aliexpress direkt lieferung aus china feier a fireworks pulver verstehe
verstehe boom party popper
also ohne scheiß wenn man so was bestellt da muss ich doch keiner
wundern wenn da wenn wenn wenn das wenn du das bei der polizei abholen darfst
oder das kann ja alles sein diese päckchen das kann ja alles sein
bis jetzt auf der liste das traurige ist dass es in der heutigen zeit
tatsächlich irgendwo möglich ist nur weil wir uns jetzt irgendwie was auf
aliexpress angeguckt haben und irgendwie ein paar buzzwords stichwörter im
stream gesagt haben gleich gleich vorbei
naja gut genug aliexpress also wir sehen wenn man sehr risikobereit ist und aus
china teile kauft dann kann man über über 30 euro noch mal einsparen vom
nassbild muss doch noch ein bisschen billigere 60 watt netzteile geben
bei amazon was da das günstigste 60 watt netzteile ist wobei ich halt denke die
meisten leute haben sogar ein so müssen sich gar keins kaufen
jetzt also ich meine so diese diese wie nennt man die stelle diese stecker
netzteile da die die dicken der hat jeder von massig rumliegen von alten
geräten und die 12 volt variante dürfte auch so mit die gebräuchlichste sein
ja guckt man kriegt sogar bei amazon bisschen billiger noch aber da hat man
wahrscheinlich dann direkt in china import am start ich mein eigentlich war
so überlegt ne eigentlich wird sich ja lohnen so das billig zeug aus china zu
kaufen und dann irgendwie amazon marketplace wenn das zeug wenn das
zeug halt irgendwie was taugt
wobei die frage ist ob sich das lohnt das muss man halt mal durchrechnen
immerhin du musst immerhin das zeug her transportieren du musst natürlich
steuer dafür bezahlen du kannst du kannst es nicht so machen wie jemand der
privat bestellt in der hoffnung so nach dem motto hoffentlich merkt er soll
nichts wo ich natürlich strikt dagegen bin wenn du das halt geschäftlich macht
dann musst du das alles ordentlich machen dann ist die frage ob sich das
noch so ob sich das noch so lohnt keine ahnung ja man muss das lagern genau
denn id wie gesagt der normale stream läuft auch nur mit 4 m bit der
müsstest du denke ich auch gucken können ja das ist unser nass bild also dass
mal gucken netzteile habe ich für passt wie gucken wir gucken gerade noch mal
eine sache und zwar ob wir theoretisch was mit sparen könnten wenn wir das wenn
wir das netzteil von denen nehmen wir haben zwar ein netzteil schon gesucht aber
es gibt ja noch ein anderes
der reiser kart brauche ich glaube ich noch
den reiser kart brauchen wir noch aber die kostet 3,50 euro bei amazon
ja das lohnt sich alles nicht so wirklich netzteile netzteile wo sind sie
netzwerkkarten netzteile gibt es eigentlich so für neue usvs netzteile
so und wo kann man sich jetzt die bauform angucken
sieht es irgendwo kann man sich über die bauform angucken
die fuhr ist
guck mal es gibt ja auch noch billigere varianten
auch noch billigere varianten
wir könnten sogar
bei der sogar mal der cpu bei der bei der netzteile können wir wirklich noch
gar noch zehn euro irgendwie sparen wenn man unbedingt will
dann machen wir doch mal die da rein
hat die hat die den den den stecker ja die hat auch den stecker
ok die wunschliste hinzufügen das und schlüssen das und andere werfen wir raus
sagt es ist schon immer billiger wo kann ich billig nass hd festplatten kaufen
wuchs super geiz als am besten das könnten wir noch mal gucken
wie sieht es dann mit festplatten bei aliexpress aus oder hart disk so man
da jetzt
ok ne das sind die üblichen verdächtigen sind da auch nicht viel
billiger als hier
die sind da auch nicht viel billiger als hier guck mal was das hier kostet
festplatten hat es 3,5 sasa was preis pro terabyte ja preis pro terabyte
nee nee umgedreht moment 21 wtf so rum endlich mit bestpreis hat es klingt ja
vertrauenswürdig und vor hast du da eine halbe festplatte gekauft bei hart disk
rejected
geiler namen
dies hier 320 g da fack dass es überhaupt noch platten in der größe
gibt ok warte mal wir gucken mal ab ein terabyte ab ab ein terabyte
hier das günstigste ist das günstigste ist 34 aber da kriegst du fast schon ssd
für oder ok nicht ganz nicht ganz eine kleine ssd kriegst du dafür aber locker
also wenn man noch ein bisschen weiter optimieren kriegen wir vielleicht
sogar noch eine terabyte platte beim nass mit dabei ich weiß es ist fast
schon drinne preislich ach nee moment vergesst vergesst was ich gesagt habe wir
sind ziemlich genau preislich dort wo wir hin wollen weil die netzwerkarte ist
nicht dabei die netzwerkarte kostet aber 30 euro
oder ich muss gleich ins bett und warum muss arbeiten gehen habe kein bock
platten kauft man doch bei wish ich habe bei wish noch nie was gekauft
wish shopping made fun ach das ist die seite die will dass man sich registriert
wenn man sobald man drauf geht da kaufe ich nichts ob doch erst mal
registrierungszeug abgreifen bevor man was machen kann
wie viel zeug schlaufen ab sind die chinesen schon am start hier
ich danke für die follows guck mal nach wenn ich noch alles sehe in der
history sonny ray lp mechur pils pusten der peter des boy timmy cyber dos 233
hoana und asiox und dass die am dabei seit im streben
was ist warum sollte man da kaufen was was also wie gesagt gesagt die seite
nichts aber ich kenne mich bei shopping seit noch nicht großartig aus was
genau ist der vorteil von dieser seite
ok ein terabyte mal gucken was die billigste schiena disc
teurer das lohnt sich aber gar nicht
da keiner
et recto
die da okay da kommt musik die war super entspannend er fabian würde sagen lull
habe ich nie gehört weil ich immer saunen aus hatte was genau sind drop
schippe
ihr werft ihr mit zeug um euch was mir überhaupt nix sagt das sind drop schippe
was die sortierung war bei all immer auf best match
price ich suche nach ein terabyte hartdisk android 3.0
ja ok ein bisschen billiger sind die platten bei aliexpress aber nicht lohnt
sich nicht wir sind schon wirklich verdammt billig bei oder
ich meine wir sind wirklich verdammt billig bei
10 genas für irgendwie 145 euro das ist doch wirklich nix ok nice
ja ich werde mal bestellen und dann mache ich dann wahrscheinlich auch wenn
es am start ist ein video drüber wobei ich vorher eigentlich das video
eigentlich müsste ich vorher das video zu 10 gigabit netzwerk machen damit ich
danach das video zu 10 gigabit nass machen kann weil sonst ist es irgendwie
ein bisschen falsch rum
10 gigabit sein oder genas also ich weiß q nap hatten relativ günstig ist
relativ günstig was irgendwie 450 oder so ja genau irgendwie so in dem dreh
ist das überhaupt 10 g ne wat 10 hundert
ja genau das hier meine ich das kostet 450
und bei denen kostet ist das ist das jetzt das mit 10 g
büro markt ag auch toller namen so wirklich voll nur nach 15 irgendwie
ist jetzt ein 10 genas sieht nicht aus wie 10 genas
a creed games a verstehe erklärt uns gerade was tropf shipping ist und da sagt tropf
shipping ist dass du sachen verkaufst ohne lager und eigene produktion also
wenn man dir eine bestellung eingeht bestellst du bei anbieter xy das
produkt nur mit dem versand daten vom kunden ach so also im prinzip genauso wie
ich zum beispiel die nvidia gewinnspiele gemacht haben
wiegt die dinger hatte ich jetzt im größten teil auch nicht
man hat die bestellung zum ende durch ja also das ist kein 10 g oder wo steht
er die netzwerke geschwindigkeit
buchspieler hat meist eine gute beschreibung
ne ja gut dann ist das qnap mit 550 euro oder was es war die 450 euro echt das
günstigste
moment eine usw eine usw für 24 euro
der power walker was ist was wie der daywalker bloß bloß für netzter der sieht
guck mal sogar schon die fugen hier sehen nicht richtig passend aus
wer kennt sie nicht die guten power walker usw oder was auch immer das
genau sein soll ne das ist einfach nur ein 12 volt netzteil warum auch immer das
bei usw steht was ist das
aus wie laut sprecher
was ist was ist das überhaupt 500 volt aber das ist nur usw usb usb
ich muss gucken was das ist muss ich mal gucken was das ist weil wenn es
sagen wir so selbst wenn es die üblichste krab usw ist für 25 euro kann sich da
echt nicht beschweren
das sieht mir echt aus wie ne usw aber warum kostet die nur 25 euro
die kostet gar nicht nur 25 euro die kostet eigentlich normalerweise 60 euro
ok
schon wieder der power walker also wenn es interessiert ich habe das ding hier
cyber power ich kann jetzt gar nicht so genau sagen wo ist meine meine usw
das die fette jeder jeder habe ich genau das meine usw und bis jetzt hat die auch
sehr zuverlässig und gut funktioniert ich habe erst gestern wieder den stecker
rausgezogen um den strun das stromes gerät um zu stöpseln
kein ding und auch das eine mal wo ich mich dran erinnern kann wo ausfall war
wunderbar funktioniert dann als der techniker an einem strom verteiler
rum gewurschtet hat und mir die sicherung rausgemacht haben für ein paar
minuten hat auch wunderbar funktioniert und als das letzte mal so ein bisschen
geflackert hat das licht und alles gedönst und auch kein problem ja
management card ist da nicht drin aber du hast nur usb anschluss das ist das
reicht mir was ein usb anschluss ok ne das stimmt jetzt
ane das ist für zum zum für telefonkabel was ein usb anschluss
also reicht mir usb anschluss und dann habe ich auf dem server einfach den
monitoring den laufen was guckt
ich meine es ist auch ein bisschen überflüssig daheim quasi ich sitze hier
an meinem arbeitsplatz und meine meine rek steht ja quasi in so einem klein
in so einer kleinen abstellkammer gefühlt 2 meter hinter mir da brauche
ich keine remote management funktionen für die usf ein bisschen aber die usf
ist echt ganz cool ich glaube die hier sind an der batterie die hier sind nur
überspannungs geschützt also die sind batterie überspannungs geschützt die
sind auch nur überspannungs geschützt man kann auch eine management karte
rein machen wenn man dann wirklich scharf ist man kann sich halt die dinge
anzeigen lassen wie was er gerade was gerade das zeug daran sieht wie die
batterien geladen sind aber hat man nie drauf geguckt aber an sich funktioniert
wirklich gut sobald es außer armen reichweite ist
remote
bei allem außer armen reichweite remote ganz in meinem sinne
ja lass mal überlegen was muss ich dann überhaupt bestellen also was müsste ich
dann bestellen zum ausprobieren habe ich habe ich kommt die tage habe ich habe
ich eigentlich müsste ich mir nur das bord bestellen eigentlich müsste ich
mir nur das bord bestellen bestellen wenn das am besten ja ja die sind gut die
haben keine versandkosten den habe ich schon viel zeug bestellt die haben ich
mal fast gar maß hier cloud fox die haben sich dann am letzten tag vom paypal
käufer schutz gemeldet als der abgelaufen ist und die haben sich bis zum
letzten tag ausgereizt bis sich quasi der tach bevor sich paypal eingeschaltet
hat geht versandkosten bei minefactory lohnen sich immer nicht
nehmen 6 7 euro gucken was es bei amazon kostet 82
nope dann bestelle ich sie hier die liefern auch schnell ja ich muss mir
im endeffekt nur das bord bestellen der rest habe ich da ich meine ich habe eine
andere ssd da und haben andere ram riegel da aber das ist ja kein großes
problem oder mein faktor ist bei dir um die ecke gut bieten die ab kannst du abholen ab
null uhr kosten ne auch hätten wir das nicht gestern machen können
hätten wir das nicht gestern machen können gebadet heute bleibe ich
bestimmt nicht bis null uhr auf da gibt es bestimmt bots die das für einen
machen oder cpu ist schon dabei ja cpu ist schon dabei ist alles dabei alles
dabei außer die netzwerkarte die musste der bei bei 30 euro gebraucht holen die
können wir nicht als neues teil von geiz als einfügen weil er kostet 500
euro oder so vor gastrine ich muss morgen aber ich kann ich bin höchstens
noch allerhöchstens eine stunde am start allerhöchstens
cpu schon dabei findest du ein schönes bild das gefällt mir wirklich gut
stelle es morgen stelle das morgen früh vor der arbeit aus amazon pay kann ich
besser in ruhe noch mal angucken so kann wie kann ich kann ich die
kann man die liste irgendwie scheren
günstigste anbieter falle artikel ermitteln machen wir mal
naja man ist so der große unterschied oder
scheren ja wie schert man seine wie schert man seine wunschliste aber muss
okay da muss man account ich habe ja einen account ich weiß bloß die daten
ich fotografiere mir jetzt einfach mal den bildschirm ab im jahr 2019 kann ich
es morgen bestellen vielleicht vielleicht ich habe mir nämlich
überlegt also ich habe gesagt ich will ein paar videos machen ein paar
technik videos ich habe mir überlegt ob ich das so mache für das 10 gigabit
video das 10 gigabit video wird ja ungefähr so aussehen von der
empfehlung her
das 10 gigabit wird im endeffekt so von der empfehlung aussehen ja die
netzwerkarten plus diesen switch hier bloß alternativ zeige ich den anderen
noch mit den gigabit mit den gigabit ports da habe ich mir überlegt ob ich
nicht mal nett sein soll und wir quasi einordnen da kann ich nämlich auch
direkt im video zeigen alles und danach weil ich brauchte nicht ich habe den
anderen den größeren mit den gigabit ports noch dabei nicht dann direkt
gleich verlosungsstelle mache im video das wäre doch nice da kann man dann
sogar gleich direkt loslegen mit seinem 10g netzwerke weil die chancen dass
man gewinnt ist halt relativ relativ gering wird da nicht 1g ach so ja ein
port ein port der hier ist 1g der rest ist 10g sfp plus
der den der ist gedacht für management zwecke aber wahrscheinlich kannst du
den so wie ich mikrotik kenne da kannst ja alles für alles irgendwie verwenden
den kannst du bestimmt auch einfach so franzisco ist ein konsolen port konsolen
port
morgen ist eine 240 g ssd für 12 euro in der flash sein du meinst bei aliexpress
oder wo meinst du
wann haben gaming mainboards ein 10g port gibt es schon gibt es schon gibt es
schon gibt schon ein paar also ich habe eins mit 10g on board
lohnt es sich denn schon auf 10g um zu rösten als heim anwender wie gesagt wir
haben uns jetzt ja angeguckt und also du kriegst wir haben es jetzt ja ich habe
wir haben es jetzt ausgerechnet du kriegst für 160 euro in 10 gigabit
switch du kriegst für 30 euro das stück die
netzwerkarte da musst du noch ein paar kabel rechnen und für wenn die
netzwerkarten schon hast für ungefähr 150 für 215 euro kriegst du eine nass
ohne platten haben wir gerade zusammengestellt also sagen wir mal so
wenn du 500 euro hast bist du bist du dabei ohne platten
platten kommen natürlich immer noch oben drauf aber die müsstest du ja auch für
den andern für normales nass holen
ja und wenn du natürlich nicht mit deinem netzwerk übertragen willst an
größeren daten dann brauchst du auch das ist richtig was der flixkode hat da
brauchst auch kein 10 10 g was sagst du morgen gibt es eine für 10 gene ssd
abkommen
benutzt das so selten diese die quasi die angebotgeschichte wo sieht man das
denn muss man als krollen bis man bis man soweit ist ssd boah das ist billig
alter das ist billig natürlich wie der weltbekannte marke netak wer hat noch
wer hat noch nie was von netak ssd gehört aber das ist echt sehr günstig
250 240 g 12 euro
mein aktuell das sind doch mal angebote das da mal ordentlich
was usb flash was
was oder wo steht das was inventor
ich sehe es nicht was ihr gesehen habt
auf dem bild von der ssd achier der usb flash inventor ja gut auf die auf die
auf die texte in china seiten darf man ja wirklich nichts geben ok aber schafft
denn angeblich schafft sie 420 mb read 450 mb right angeblich netak mal gucken ob
es dazu den review gibt und die gibt sogar ein gibt sogar hier zu kaufen
nur wenn nur wenn china import ist
direkt lief von china wahrscheinlich ist wahrscheinlich alle aus shang zheng
da kommen sie ja alle irgendwie her aber man muss mal echt sagen also die also
12 euro für eine ssd ist wirklich ordentlich ja da kann man sich nicht
beschweren
kompanie claims zu inventen usb flashtreifen bestimmt ganz bestimmt ganz
bestimmt 240 g 240 g morgen in elf stunden also sprich um 9 9 24 ja um 9 oder um 9
uhr morgen gibt es bei aliexpress und 42 g ssd ich meine ihr müsst natürlich
wieder mit ein bisschen längere versandzeiten rechnen aber aliexpress
standard kostet ganzes 60 cent shipping kost
und muss muss da halt 21 bis 47 tage warten
wieviel terabytes schreiben sie garantieren steht an der drinnen
highly efficient effizient im im verbessern der übertragungsgeschwindigkeit
aha das ist die die knucke musik passt voll zu ssd ist passt voll zu ssd oder
das ist also typische anzweigen das ist ein bisschen scheiß drauf dass hier 64
g steht und dass da oben die 250 240 g ist vollkommen egal
eben kriegen den gegen den speed gezeigt
upgrade expand capacity essential was man kann man kann mit einem tool von
denen die größe seiner ssd verbessern aha
was auch immer was auch immer das genau machen soll
iSpeed SATA interface SATA 2 auch krass turn on for about 10 seconds was genau
wollte es damit sagen die geht nach zehn sekunden wieder aus oder die wollen
uns sagen die platte braucht zehn sekunden zum starten das wäre beide
schlecht ssd die zehn sekunden braucht zum angehen ist crap oder ssd die sich
die nicht nur zehn sekunden anschalten ist auch ziemlich knapp game fast
loading not stuck quite operation ja da haben sie da haben sie recht fast
loading not stuck das ist auch gut high performance ja das haben sie uns ja das
haben sie schon fünf mal gezeigt jetzt
zehn sekunden wie 99 prozent of computers try immediately
ach die wollen uns sagen mein rechner ist durch diese ssd zehn sekunden
gebootet oder was ha ha pupke spielen sehr gut das verstehe ich pupke ist in
china übelst angesagt pupke ist der schitt in china
und pupke kann auch ssd gebrauchen
das aber doch eher mb 2 oder das ist auch pupke war nie da das sind die die
keine ssd haben ist ja das sind die ohne netack ssd die müssen warten und die
der hier ist schon fertig und kann sie wechseln high performance improved
speed in picture loading for photoshop hier was die alles können
sogar unter linux funktioniert sie muss oder krasse ssd sein
make strong and powerful sammer wie die seite heute gar nicht mehr auf mit
lobpreisung über diese ssd das ist die ausführlichste beschreibung zu der
ssd die ich je gesehen habe also anpreisungsmäßig high perform wie oft
wollen sie uns das dann noch erzählen nur wird nur von glücklichen leuten
hergestellt die ssd
tipp 1
ok ja erzähl uns wie sie den speicherplatz berechnet haben
krasse tipp tipp 2 f32 sagt korrekt
in das sieben abgehört die beschreibung die hört wirklich immer auf
about netack ok was was kann so geiles schenzen die sind alle die sind alle in
schenzen alle sagt mir ein ein china technologie ding also die hier so am
start nicht in schenzen sind alle das scheint so wer fällt nicht
entsprechen ist in deutschland ein wir haben nichts vergleichbares aber sie
sind alle da samsung samsung ist ja auch nicht in china china first mobile
zertifizierte ssd
self help shopping guide 5 star feedback also wir haben jetzt gelernt
die haben es übelst drauf und morgen um
morgen um 9 gibt es für 12 euro und 42 g ssd was preislich ziemlich poggers ist
die haben den usb stick erfunden das habe ich jetzt hier gar nicht gelesen
wird es da auch drinnen
das erzählen sie wahrscheinlich auf ihrer homepage dass sie den usb stick
erfunden haben da kannst du dir anti kat klops holen aber nur aber nur für
mann lasst es mal nicht lasst es mal nicht die feministen hören das ist nur
für mann
aufhängen aber alles in allem ich muss echt sagen ich ich mag aliexpress
wirklich für das was es ist nämlich wo man sich super günstig technik teile
aus china kaufen kann und ich würde halt nicht unbedingt dazu raten jetzt
irgendwelche kritischen sachen dazu kaufen also ich würde nicht unbedingt
sagen wir mal netzteile da kaufen oder sowas oder irgendwelche datenträger auf
die ich mich wirklich verlassen muss aber für so dinge wie open close
fenster fenster und türen sensoren arduino boards und sowas in der richtung
ja oder kabels ich habe hier jede menge ob ich die kiste weiß ich so so diese
jumper du ponn kabel wie das täuscht genau heißt und und so eine kiste mit
widerständen und gedöns drinnen als aliexpress
das zeug kostet da nix kabels genau das kostet da nix das ist wirklich
sauberlich billig wenn man usb kabel braucht ganz ganz irgendwie 30er pack
kaufen in china kostet nichts oder über wachungs kameras aus china mal gucken ob
es meine überwachungskamera bei aliexpress gibt meine meine tür
gegensprecherlage wie ist denn der hersteller noch mal ich habe vergessen
ds kb kb moment moment wie ist der hersteller vor meiner vor meiner kamera
hickwischen hickwischen kb vandal resistanz sonst was das da ist er
glaube ich das hässliche ding ja ob es die baliexpress gibt
aber teuer ob sie für die ja ich habe sie für die hälfte gekriegt
vandal resistent na also falls wir twitch chat irgendwann mal die das die tür
gegensprecherlage antreten will dann habt ihr schlechte karten ich habe die
china vandal resistent dorf phone am start
das stimmt 96 aber ich will ja keine 5000 stück kauft vor allem für für so
aduino bots und sowas da lohnt sich das oder halt für technik krams aber auch diese
setz aus kabel aus diese elektrik elektronik sind bei aliexpress nicht
verkehrt wie lange noch sie möglichst noch 20 minuten
ob die auch ax resistent ist ja muss ausprobieren
weißt jetzt ja wo ich wohne in laut amazon in karlstein also ax testen ob sie
ax resistent ist
das fake lego würde ich mal sagen oder
das ist feig feig china lego
feig schien schiener feig lego
daraus trinken würde ich auch nicht sogar das lego menschen es sieht aus
wie ein echtes lego menschen aber das wort lego kommt nicht in ein mal auf der
seite vor
aliexpress
moment
was er soll erst mal die zähle putzen bevor es ist
photoshop skills auf ein halbtausend
aus der schlecht
ja das video mit dem klo war vorher ja natürlich natürlich
ist das billig gemacht ist das billig gemacht die die ist doch auch aus
photoshop entstanden du schmierst in die creme drauf und kriegst größere
busen durch schiener cremen jetzt bestimmt auch für männer ganz bestimmt
gut ok unser nassbill ist fertig leute ich muss morgen arbeiten gehen ich habe
zwar überhaupt kein bock aber das ist nicht so weiter will ich wenn ich auf der
arbeit ist das alles sehr gut das hält sich in meinen grenzen
ich noch rasieren vorher
ja ich gehe mich mal rasieren jetzt
also gut mal schauen ich wie gesagt ich habe mir vorgenommen jetzt
regelmäßiger zu streamen die letzten paar letzten zwei wochen hat es ja gut
funktioniert da war ich ja fast jeden tag und ich probiere morgen früh meine
youtube partner nicht youtube partner twitch ich laber manchmal ein blödsinn
sprain auf meine twitch partnergeschichte zu connecten das ginge
heute nicht
was machst du da eigentlich bei youtube nix
warum ist die die seite so klein hat hat
ja macht das mal flow 690 und berichte uns
der arbeit was auf der arbeit mache da haben wir ein kommando zu oder sebaro
haben wir da ein kommando zu
egal hat wieder kein kommando zu haben erzähle ich dir kurz ich kümmere mich
hauptsächlich um unsere software repos da wo unser ganzes hauskorb drin ist
und um den release ablauf von unserer software ganz grob gesagt und
sauber konfiguration
und dass die sauber konfiguration quasi dann zu dem jeweiligen release auch
passt
also quasi release management schrägstrich defops um mit modernen
buzzwords zu beschreiben oder um nicht zu sagen full stack serverless
microservices headless repo owner
ich habe es irgendjemanden mehr hosten können
ignorierst du mich wirklich
hab nicht gesehen dass du was geschrieben hast was dann kannst du den link mal
posten zu den 12 ternarbeiten ist
wir haben schon zugemacht irgendwo bei aliexpress aliexpress daily
flash deals hier ist aliexpress flash deals gibt es auf upcoming und scrolls
durch bis du die ssd findest
12 exabyte
ok leute macht's gut wir sehen uns hoffentlich morgen
bisher zur
Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal!